un jeune homme de 16 ans a été inculpé
aujourd'hui d'homicide volontaire et ce
au bout de sept mois d'enquêté le 28
septembre dernier on découvrait en
lorraine le corps de deux petits garçons
le crâne fracassé bernard derty fr3
laurel consternation à montigny-lès-metz
le meurtrier présumé d'alexandre de
cyril trouvé mort le 28 septembre
dernier le visage et le crâne fracassé
par de grosses pierres à cet endroit au
sommet de cette pente au milieu de ses
wagons sncf a été identifié par les
policiers de metz il s'agit d'un jeune
garçon 16 ans et demi il en aura 17 en
juin prochain
il est apprenti cuisinier dans un grand
restaurant de metz c'est à la suite
d'une enquête extrêmement minutieuse que
les srpj après sept mois de travail de
recoupement d'interrogatoire est parvenu
à identifier le meurtrier
il a été interpellé mardi matin et gardé
à vue à l'hôtel de police où il aurait
avoué être l'auteur de ce double meurtre
s'est trouvée quand même on dirait un
peu suffoquée parce que ce produit ne
s'y attendait pas et comment dirais-je
même vu dans son travail on fait dire
qu'il avait une conduite irréprochable
que c'était un site et même un exemple
pour tout le monde il était gentil doux
jamais décembre chant pouvait pas y
avait rien qui pouvait se poser comme
quoi ça pouvait lui ai même que dans les
six mois on ne revient pas pu succès des
accessoires
le meurtrier présumé habitait la même
rue que le jeune alexandre beckrich
cette rue v les îlots soit en septembre
dernier ont été retrouvés morts les deux
jeunes garçons de 8 ans alexandre et
cyril jeune meurtrier qui était inculpé
ce soir et écroué au quartier des
mineurs à la prison de metz queuleu
ouverture à metz du procès du meurtrier
présumé de deux garçons âgés de 8 ans le
procès de patrick s'est ouvert à huis
clos devant la cour d'assises
le jeune homme avait 16 ans au moment
des faits arrêté sept mois plus tard il
avait avoué avant de se rétracter à metz
jean-jacques bâti en début d'audience
nous n'avons pu apercevoir qu un jeune
homme masse balle le cheveux roux
s'asseoir dans le box des accusés
à quelques mètres de lui les pièces à
conviction deux vélos de cross avec
lesquelles s'amuser
les enfants le jour du meurtre ainsi que
cinq grosses pierres les armes du crime
ensuite la porte du palais de justice
s'est refermé sur un procès qui débute
deux ans après l'arrestation de patrick
deux années pendant lesquelles il a
souvent changé d'avis dans un premier
temps il avoue le double meurtre et
donne plusieurs détails
édifiant puis ensuite se rétracte
estimant avoir craqué devant les
policiers
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on le questionne sur
ses premiers aveux il reste silencieux
ne donne aucune explication sur les
fameux détails
aujourd'hui les nous espèrons commencé à
faire part de leurs conclusions suivront
ensuite 40 témoins puis le rapport des
policiers qui ont recueilli les premiers
aveux de patrick un moment qui sera
certainement l'un des points forts de ce
procès prévu en principe sur quatre
jours 18 ans depuis quelques jours et
condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
patrick est depuis hier soir le plus
jeune condamné à perpétuité en france
il n'avait que 16 ans au moment des
faits oui 16 ans lorsque patrick tu as à
montigny-lès-metz deux petits garçons
âgés de 8 ans on retrouve à leur corps
le crâne fracassé à coups de pierres
hier soir les jurés de la cour d'assises
de la moselle ont refusé à patrick
l'excusent de son jeune âge
jean-jacques bazié et faire 3 lorraine
patrick avait 16 ans le jour du double
meurtre de montigny-lès-metz à peine
majeur pour son procès il est devenu
après deux heures de délibéré le plus
jeune condamné à perpétuité de france à
huit clos les jurés placé pendant trois
jours devant les cinq grosses pierres
qui ont servi à fracasser les têtes de
cyril et alexandre place et aussi devant
les deux vélos avec lesquels jouer les
enfants le jour du meurtre
les jurés n'ont reconnu aucune
circonstance atténuante ni excuse de
minorité
à l'annoncé du verdict la salle est
restée silencieuse et patrick n'a pas
manifesté la moindre émotion
il a simplement déclaré je suis innocent
je suis sincère
une innocence qu'il clame depuis deux
ans après avoir dans un premier temps
avoué le double crime
sa seule arme judiciaire désormais un
pourvoi en cassation que son avocat
maître baker peut déposer dans les cinq
prochains jours sinon patrick sera
transférée vers le centre d'orientation
de fresnes avant d'être incarcéré dans
une centrale
le système judiciaire français ne
prévoyant encore aucune peine
incompressible
patrick peut espérer sortir dans quinze
vingt ans il aura alors la quarantaine
il est rare que des magistrats acceptent
de rouvrir un dossier jugé concernant un
crime et pourtant la commission de
révision de la cour de cassation vient
d'ordonner un supplément d'enquêté sur
un double meurtre commis en 1986 en
lorraine pour ce double meurtre
un garçon âgé de 16 ans a été condamné à
la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
il semblerait que ce soit francis
heaulme ce tueur en série déjà condamné
pour deux meurtres est poursuivi pour
une dizaine d'autres qui soit le vrai
coupable commentaires dominique
verdeilhan casqués et protégés escorté
patrick dils apparaît lors de la
reconstitution 86 comme le coupable
idéal
après 36 heures de garde à vue il avoue
le double meurtre d'alexandre et de
cyril puis il se rétracte les deux
jeunes garçons ont été massacrés à coups
de pierres en septembre 86 le long d'une
voie ferrée
trois ans plus tard la cour d'assises de
metz fait de patrick dils âgé alors de
18 ans le plus jeune condamné à
perpétuité de france depuis bientôt dix
ans ses parents s'élèvent contre cette
condamnation sans preuve on a cherché un
coup parce qu'il fallait calmer
l'opinion publique et à ce moment là il
y avait aussi beaucoup de meurtres
d'enfants
alors on a prouvé son patron aujourd'hui
la commission de révision de la cour de
cassation décide de rouvrir le dossier
la justice dispose d'un nouveau suspect
et ce n'est pas un inconnu
francis heaulme a déjà été condamné
trois fois et mises en examen dans neuf
dossiers il n'a pas avoué le double
assassinat mais il reconnaît avoir été
sur les lieux du crime en septembre 86
pour l'avocat de patrick dils cela
suffirait à innocenter son client
l'aveu que ce garçon a passé alors qu'il
était mineur au moment des faits et au
moment de sa garde à vue
ce n'est pas un n'a vu convaincant
d'abord parce qu'il a été donnée par une
personne extrêmement fragile et
vulnérable d'après les experts l'avocat
des parties civiles lui parle d' aveux
crédible je crois qu'on peut pas on peut
pas imaginer qu'on ait pu avoir inventé
cela ou qu'il y a eu des détails qu'ils
aient pu être inventées ou données ou
imaginer c'est impossible
franchement c'est un peu aussi la
justice s'est elle trompée de coupable
aux magistrats de la cour de cassation
de répondre patrick dils lui est en
prison depuis 12 ans on ne peut pas
encore parler d'erreur judiciaire mais
fait rarissime on s'achemine vers une
révision de la condamnation de patrick
dils en janvier 89 la cour d'assises de
la moselle le condamné à la perpétuité
pour le meurtre de deux enfants
aujourd'hui alors qu'il a déjà purgé 12
ans de prison
le parquet général s'est déclaré
favorable à la révision de son procès
clément weill-raynal myriam métaoui
depuis que son fils patrick est en
prison
jacqueline revient parfois le long de
cette voie ferrée ou deux petits garçons
de 8 ans fut retrouvé assassiné en 1986
quelques mois plus tard les enquêteurs
arrêtèrent patrick un adolescent alors
âgé de 17 ans qui avoue a le double
meurtre avant de se rétracter désaveu
auquel n'ont jamais cru séparant le
paraguay
ça c'est comme je vous dis moi on lui a
pas donné à manger ni à boire lettera
garde à vue il ya certes moi dit si tu
lui dis que c'est toi tu verras tu es
parents et or à manger à boire d'après
moi c'est ça quand on est jeune la
chambre de patrick est resté tel quel
était le jour de son arrestation une
chambre d'adolescent
patrick a aujourd'hui 30 ans et a passé
la moitié de sa vie en prison
mais il ya un an un fait nouveau est
capital a été porté à la connaissance
des enquêteurs francis heaulme le tueur
en série déjà plusieurs fois condamné
vivait à l'époque du drame à proximité
du lieu où les corps des deux enfants
ont été retrouvés
une révélation qui a incité l'avocat de
la famille dils a déposé une requête en
révision
on espère qu'elle sera blanchi douze ans
après
il serait resté douze ans pour rien en
prison oui bien sûr il y a les aveux
mais patrick avait à l'époque 17 ans il
vivait en famille à proximité de la voie
ferrée
des voisins ont affirmé l'avoir aperçu
dans la rue le jour du meurtre
un dossier bien fragile compte tenu de
la révélation de la présence de francis
heaulme sur les lieux du crime
c'est ce qui a motivé cet après midi le
réquisitoire de l'avocat général de la
cour de cassation qui s'est déclaré
favorable à une révision du procès
patrick est aujourd'hui toujours détenu
à la prison de toul
il saura le 21 juin prochain si la
justice décide ou non de le remettre en
liberté
la décision doit tomber dans une heure
patrick dils emprisonné depuis plus de
dix ans pour le meurtre de deux enfants
à montigny les metz en moselle saura
alors si son procès révisé de nouveaux
éléments dans leur quête avait amené le
procureur de la république a demandé à
la cour de cassation la révision du
procès procédure extrêmement rares en
france fanny vernis et rémy poissonnier
dans moins d'une heure
ils seront fixés depuis 12 ans monsieur
et madame deals attendent cette décision
12 ans qui clame l'innocence de leur
fils patrick condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité pour le meurtre
de deux enfants pour les parents
même si leur fils a avoué avant de se
rétracter
il n'est pas coupable la police leur
faire avouer de force comme ma femme m'a
dit tout à l'heure tu as raté parentois
à manger à boire si tu dis que c'est toi
et ça j'ai toujours pensé à ça
le 26 septembre 1986 alexandre et cyril
8 ans sont retrouvés morts lapider le
long d'une voie ferrée
sept mois plus tard un adolescent de 16
ans est arrêté patrick dils à vous puis
se rétracte en 1989 sa peine fait de lui
l'un des plus jeunes condamnés à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
mais un nouvel élément vient relancer la
faire un tueur en série francis heaulme
étaient sur les lieux le jour du crime
francis heaulme a déjà été condamné
trois fois par la justice et mis en
examen dans cette autre meurtre
même si ni les avoir tué ilan mais
curieusement avoir vu des enfants près
de la voie ferrée le jour du crime mais
pour l'avocat de la partie civile
la présence de francis heaulme le
disculpant rien patrick dils je crois
toujours à la culpabilité et de deal ce
patrick elle ressort à mon sens de ses
aveux ou si bien devant la police que
devant le juge d'instruction
elle ressort de la reconstitution telle
qu'elle a été faite
elle ressort du fait qu'à partir du
moment où il a il s'est rétracté sur ses
aveux qu'il n'a jamais donné
d'explication il a toujours dit je n'ai
rien à dire
cet après midi la commission de révision
va trancher le cas de patrick dils
si la présence de francis heaulme lui
apparaît comme un élément nouveau
important patrick dils pourrait être
rejugée un jour et peut-être même libéré
de la prison de toul dans les heures à
venir en france une décision importante
et surtout très rare dans le domaine de
la justice la commission de révision de
la cour de cassation a en effet ordonné
aujourd'hui le réexamen du procès de
patrick dils
ce jeune homme a déjà passé 13 ans en
prison après avoir avoué le meurtre de
deux enfants
mais depuis l' enquête a permis de
prouver que le tueur en série francis
heaulme se sont retrouvés dans la région
au moment des faits patrick dils restera
tout de même en prison jusqu'au prochain
procès u2 est hervé gutman oui un
nouveau procès noah une libération
la commission de révision de la cour de
cassation a rendu une décision contraste
et les parents de patrick dils
incarcéré depuis 13 ans aurait
évidemment souhaité pouvoir l'embrasser
dès ce soir
mais après tant de déconvenues c'est
déjà un premier pas ça fait 13 ans trois
mois et 15 jours que nous apportons ça
et on a eu plus confiance parce que
j'étais déçu corvette point que ça on
est bien en ce jour de septembre 86 deux
enfants sont retrouvés le long de la
voie ferrée le crâne fracassé à coups de
pierres un peu plus tard un adolescent
de 16 ans est arrêté très vite patrick
dils à vous donne des détails troublants
puis se rétracte il est condamné à la
perpétuité
deux recours en cassation seront
rejetées et la présence de francis
heaulme eux le tueur en série sur les
lieux et le jour du drame change tout il
reconnaît que des enfants lui ont jeté
des pierres mais il nie toute
implication
statistiquement qu'elle ait la chance
qu'ils étaient sur le lieu du crime le
jour du crime à l'heure du crime qui
avait vu les victimes et qu'il eut un
mobile est assassiné finirait par faire
c'est toute la question se pose au juge
de répondre à cette question
en attendant patrick dils reste en
prison la présence de francis heaulme
est certes un fait nouveau a estimé la
commission mais il subsiste contre le
jeune homme une charge sérieuse
la question était de savoir est il
opportun de le remettre en liberté
aujourd'hui sachant qu'il devra
comparaître détenu puisque c'est une
obligation du code
il doit se constituer prisonnier alors
peut-être c'est quelque chose qui a joué
en sa défaveur
ce qui est important c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la révision et été
prononcé la patience après tant d'années
passées en prison
patrick dils va devoir en faire preuve
avant que l'on reconnaisse peut-être son
innocence toujours au chapitre
judiciaire devant la cour de cassation
l'éventuelle révision de la condamnation
de patrick dils condamné lien onze ans
pour le meurtre de deux enfants cette
requête en révision amènerait à
considérer que le tueur en série francis
heaulme présent à l'époque des faits sur
les lieux du crime pourraient en être
l'auteur valérie ermite christian galley
pour les familles des victimes
c'est une large blessure qui s'ouvre à
nouveau pour les parents de patrick dils
c'est en revanche le dernier espoir de
voir peut-être un jour leur fils
innocenté important de notre vie puis
surtout de la vie de patrick en 1986
alexandre et cyril et 8 ans ont retrouvé
mort frappé très violemment à coups de
pierres le long d'une voie ferrée
sept mois plus tard patrick dils alors
âgé de 16 ans passent aux aveux des
aveux très précis très détaillé le jeune
dils se rétractera par la suite pour
clamer son innocence mais sera condamnée
à la perpétuité en 1989
ce n'est que huit ans plus tard que l'on
apprendra que francis heaulme
aujourd'hui célèbre tueur en série a
croisé les enfants à l'heure du crime
même s'il me les avoir tués un élément
nouveau très important pour l'avocate
générale mais qui ne suffit pas à
disculper patrick dils en revanche elle
demande un supplément d'information et
une analyse adn sur les pierres qui ont
servi à tuer est parfait puisque le tube
à dire ça ne pourra aboutir est ce que
depuis maintenant trois ans quatre ans
patrick dils est innocent quand système
est coupable donc l'adn c'est une
excellente idée si c'est encore possible
simplement prié donc ce sont
techniquement possible qu'on vienne pas
dire que c'est une erreur judiciaire a
sonné on n'a pas de parti pris pour ce
gars ça serait un hôte qui leur est
esquissée par aig
mais tout de même on peut pas dire que
c'est par lui comme celle vie avec leurs
convictions respectives
les familles sont parties chacune de
leur côté la justice décidera le 28 juin
du sort de patrick dils
c'est déjà en soi a presque une première
en onze ans la cour de révision d'un
statut et qu'une seule fois en matière
criminelle justice toujours à propos du
projet de loi relatifs à la présomption
d'innocence députés et sénateurs se sont
mis d'accord hier soir pour instaurer
l'enregistrement audiovisuel des
interrogatoires des mineurs en garde à
vue ce serait une nouveauté importante
une décision qui pourrait illustrer par
exemple le supplément d'information
requis dans la sphère de patrick dils
en effet hier l'avocat général de la
cour de cassation demandé un complément
d'enquêté dans cette affaire où le
condamné à perpétuité
demande la révision de son procès il est
accusé du meurtre de deux enfants et lui
même étaient âgés de 16 ans au moment
des faits explications clément
weill-raynal luc hedrich rien n'a bougé
dans la chambre de patrick depuis le
jour de son arrestation
lorsque la police est venue l'arrêter
patrick était encore presque un enfant
à 16 ans il collectionnait les soldats
en carton et lisait les bibliothèques
verte ou rose après 48 heures de garde à
vue patrick avait avoué le meurtre de
deux petits garçons âgés de 8 ans cyril
et alexandre dont les corps avaient été
retrouvés non loin de son domicile
le long d'une voie ferrée aujourd'hui
depuis sa prison patrick dils clame son
innocence
joint par téléphone il raconte dans
quelles conditions les aveux consignés
par écrit sur un procès verbal lui
aurait été suggéré
on m'a appris ce scénario puis jallet
plus qu à le redire après ce qui faisait
que je venais à ce moment là l'auteur
français ces détails c'est pas des
choses vécues ces des choses qui m'ont
été rapportés tout simplement par qui et
je dirai
les personnes qui se sont chargés de
faire mes interrogatoires à l'époque qui
se sont relayés puis qui ont mis du
coeur à l'ouvragé pour obtenir ce qu'ils
désiraient obtenir non pas obtenir les
aveux du coupable
mais obtenir les aveux un coupable ces
gens là avaient tous les éléments en
main
du dossier il n'avait qu'une chose à
faire c'est me laisse suggérer des
francophones pour billets l'âge que
j'avais à l'époque je voulais qu'une
chose c'est qu'on coûte la paire hier
devant la cour de cassation l'avocat
général a reconnu que des éléments
nouveaux apparus dans le dossier de
patrick 10 justifiait un complément
d'enquêté qui pourrait conduire à une
révision du procès reste bien sûr les
aveux du jeune garçon qui était mineur à
l'époque il aurait été intéressant a
souligné l'avocat général de disposer
des enregistrements de la garde à vue
afin de déterminer dans quelles
conditions les aveux de patrick dils ont
été obtenus dans une semaine patrick
dils se saura s'il sera ou non rejugé il
avait été condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité pour le meurtre
de deux enfants lorraine il y a plus de
dix ans la commission de révision des
procès doit statuer sur son cas
ce sont les déclarations du tueur en
série francis heaulme qui ont conduit
l'avocat de dils a déposé un recours
depuis de nouveaux témoins sont apparus
dans ce dossier enquête
estelle mathieu ifk mnr il y a plusieurs
jours dans sa prison de toul
patrick dils purge sa 14e année de
prison à 16 ans il est condamné pour le
meurtre de deux enfants
aujourd'hui il a 30 ans voici son
témoignage
je suis une certitude c'est à dire c'est
à dire que j'ai eu
on ne va pas toucher j'ai loupé son coup
mais
dépression jets l'ont été pire c'est à
dire que c'est une pression au niveau
psychologique ou
morales a du mental
retour sur une tragédie 1987 la lorraine
dans la banlieue de metz sur ces photos
patrick dils et on garde à vue pas de
mobile mais des aveux quatorze ans après
l'inspecteur chargé de l'enquêté
toujours aussi convaincu est toujours
persuadé que dit mme patry qui est bien
l'auteur du double meurtre de montigny
par contre s'il est exact qu'il ya
encore une zone dont
aujourd'hui il me paraît évident que la
justice doit tout faire aussi bien par
des tests adn que par une enquête
complémentaire pour éliminer ce doute
les zones d'ombré justement sur la base
d'un élément nouveau patrick dils a
demandé la révision de son procès
l'élément nouveau c'est la présence de
francis heaulme le tueur en série
français sur les lieux du crime le jour
des faits l'élément nouveau c'est
l'excès du temps à brasles qu'il
n'obtiendra au cours d'une audition
comme celle ci abgrall connaît bien
il a arrêté puis souvent fait avant il
expliquait qu'il déplaçait dans l'est de
la france fait le long d'une voie de
chemin de fer près poubelles et d'un pro
qui avait vu des gamins qui lui avait
jeté des pierres et que plus tard et
évolue david est justement de corriger
ces gamins qui après ses aveux et que
lorsqu'il est arrivé y avait des
policiers des gendarmes
on était mort
j'ai vu les corps préparons
dit jamais qu'il a tué quelqu'un il a
toujours rêvé les meurtres mais toujours
arriver sur les scènes de crime où il a
rencontré l'assassin qui lui a expliqué
comment ça s'était passé du la précision
en fait de ses descriptions et là on est
exactement dans le cadre d'ailleurs sur
le mode opératoire pour comment disent
exactement sa façon de faire plus
récemment et plus surprenant il ya cette
déclaration de l'un des avocats des
familles des victimes
dans son cabinet il ya un mois il a reçu
les confidences spontanée de trois
personnes celle s de deux officiers de
police d'abord et bien que d'une part le
jour de la reconstitution
plusieurs personnes âgées sont présentés
aux policiers hauts commandants des
forces de police qui gardaient les lieux
de la reconstitution pour s'étonner que
la personne qui était incriminé soit un
jeune alors que dans leur esprit celui
qui selon le témoignage des témoignages
avait fait le coup était une personne
âgée quand on sait que auld est édenté
on peut penser que peut-être ces
personnes pensé à lui
c'est d'une femme enfin marguerite
kossoko le jour des faits se trouvait
sur un balcon face à la fameuse ben ou
patrick dils était venu chercher des
timbres
quatorze ans après elle raconte et j'ai
vu monsieur venir avec un sac sur le dos
qu'est ce qui vous permet de dire que
c'est lui
écoutez sa chevelure déjà qu'il est roux
et à ce moment là qu'est ce qui s'est
passé bah lui la villa où il est rentré
chez lui c'est à dire que vous êtes en
train de dire qu'à aucun moment il ne
s'est dirigé vers les enfants jamais
jamais
jamais jamais jamais pourquoi ces
témoignages tardifs dans ce dossier que
reste-t-il des confidences des
coïncidences troublantes aucune preuve
aucun mobile et un condamné patrick dils
le 28 juin prochain
la chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation rendra son arrêt quoi qu'il en
soit la procédure est exceptionnel
pourra-t-elle conduire un jour à la
vérité chacun espère nouveau
rebondissement dans la sphère dix
condamnés à perpétuité pour le meurtre
de deux enfants 86 un commandant de
police à la retraite
présent au moment de la reconstitution
des crimes en 87 expriment de sérieux
doutes et des remords ce témoignage
capital intervient en plein délibéré de
la cour de cassation qui dira le 28 juin
s'il ya lieu ou non de réviser le procès
au maire stragier a fait toute sa
carrière dans la police à metz il était
commandant c'est lui qui spontanément
hier a souhaité revenir sur les lieux de
la tragédie 1986 montigny-lès-metz à cet
endroit deux enfants sont sauvagement
assassinée 1987 au même endroit patrick
10 alors présumé coupable participent à
la reconstitution
ce jour-là au maire stragier assurent la
sécurité des lieux
il se trouve à quelques mètres de
patrick dils quatorze ans après les
faits dans un long entretien qu'il nous
a accordé aux mères ce trajet revient
sur cette reconstitution qui selon lui
ne collait pas à la réalité
à l'époque le brigadier qui était de
service de permanence et qui a été le
premier à viser des faits sur le 17 à se
rendre sur place
présent également lors de la
reconstitution s'assure j'ai constamment
et se révoltent et même contre le fait
que l'on ne patrick dils en quelque
sorte finissait par faire tout et
n'importe quoi et notamment s'insurger
de voir que les petites poupées qui
représentait à l'époque les
victime 1 qu'il avait été chargé de
remettre en place
ce n'était pas comme ça tout aussi
troublant il se souvient de cette
vieille dame venue l'interpeller sur
place elle me dit tout de go alors
monsieur c'est donc pas le vieux
monsieur qu'on a vu avec sa bicyclette
surprise je suis revenu sur mes pages
imméditement madame comment quel vin
vieux monsieur avec une bicyclette
bah oui et elle se retourne vers ses
autres collègues dit ben oui il dit mais
attendez vous l'avais dit à la police
ben oui oui vous l'avez dit donc à la
police et on vous a entendu pas de
réponse vous connaissez rien vous a fait
venir à l'hôtel de police
non on n'a jamais revu personne car en
1997 avec cet élément nouveau la
présence de francis heaulme sur les
lieux du crime le jour des faits omer
stragier établi des rapprochements des
rapprochements avec le faciès édenté de
francis heaulme
et ce vélo qu'il ne quittait jamais cet
après-midi quand il découvre le
témoignage
les révélations d'homère stragier ont
visiblement embarrassé bernard varlet à
l'époque puis chargé de l'anc est alors
la saq et policiers qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
ben moi je pense qu'une chose que si un
fonctionnaire de police a eu ces
informations il ya 14 ans il ya quatorze
ans après dire un juge
pardon
je suis un peu ému d'en dire un peu à la
presse qu'il a eu des informations lors
de la reconstitution et qu'il en fait
seulement état aujourd'hui et jeudi
c'est un drôle de policiers est ce que
vous avez eu connaissance de ce
témoignage de vieilles dames on a
entendu des dvd en entendant on a on a
vu en tout et pour tout
quinze mille personnes dans le cadre de
cette affaire là voilà on a remué tout
le monde ni ddv d'arbres dans la vue des
dizaines et des dizaines ski mais voilà
la liste des révélations troublantes ne
s'arrête pas là il y a quelques jours
nous avons rencontré marguerite posocco
elle affirme avoir vu patrick dils le
jour du drame que vous êtes en train de
dire qu'à aucun moment il ne s'est
dirigé vers les enfances jamais jamais
jamais jamais jamais le 28 juin prochain
la chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation se prononcera sur la révision
ou non du procès de patrick vix ces
témoignages de dernière minute
conduiront t-il un jour à la vérité
chacun attend justice maintenant patrick
dils est en prison depuis 14 ans mais il
clame son innocence et demandent la
révision de son procès de nouveaux
éléments très troublants sont apparus
ces derniers mois le tueur en série
francis heaulme se trouvait en effet sur
les lieux du drame où deux enfants avait
été assassiné à coups de pierres près de
metz en 1986 aujourd'hui la cour de
cassation a demandé un supplément
d'instruction reportages et réactions
avec estelle mathieu et yves quemener
cet après midi le lieu était bien garnie
comme si tout ce qui allait se passer
devait être exceptionnelle tout à
l'heure en montant les marches du palais
de justice la famille ses avocats savez
bien que la journée d'aujourd'hui ne
serait pas une journée ordinaire
à 14 heures les cinq magistrats de la
cour de cassation devait statuer sur le
sort de leur fils ce fils de 30 ans
condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité en 1989 pour un double
homicide commis en 1986 près de metz ce
fils de 30 ans qui demandent la révision
de son procès à la lueur d'un élément
nouveau il est 14 heures
hors caméra la chambre criminelle rend
son arrêt la procédure est rarissime
elle ordonne un supplément d'instruction
et patrick dils ne sort pas soit il est
pas remis en liberté c'est à des schémas
renommée
sortira sortira blanchi vous avez vu la
cour de révision est vérifiée 1986 on
ose espérer qu'elle n'attendra pas 2014
pour vérifier l'an 2000 c'est tout le
problème
car au delà de l'élément nouveau c'est à
dire la présence de francis heaulme sur
les lieux du crime au jour des faits la
cour de cassation de voix désormais
vérifier l'emploi du temps de francis
heaulme ce jour-là rechercher son
compagnon de beuverie et saisir son
dossier médical doit figurer
l'explication de cette fameuse blessure
occasionnée le lendemain des faits à la
sortie d'audience au seul nom de francis
heaulme
les familles des victimes en bondissant
on ne demande pas mieux
vous savez c'est la vérité pour
l'opinion publique pour nous nous avons
le dossier un dossier t des câbles mais
c'est pour l'opinion publique parce que
maintenant la presse avait tout ce
qu'elle a raconté
il va bien falloir qu'on maîtrise choses
au point c'est quoi ces lieux publics
elle commence à se gratter la tête
maintenant à se dire mais qu'est ce qui
se passe à 7 ans n'étaient pas pas lui
parce qu'on arrivait à faire aujourd'hui
plus qu'hier le doute est lent le doute
sur la culpabilité de patrick 10 avec
ces derniers jours cette succession de
témoignages troublants autour de francis
heaulme
aujourd'hui la cour de cassation s'est
donné du temps demain patrie ville se
fête ses 30 ans quoi qu'il en soit la
justice devra prendre une décision
un jour ou l'autre en 1989 patrick dils
fut condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité pour le meurtre de deux
enfants de 8 ans commis à montigny les
metz en moselle
un comité de soutien de patrick dils se
bat pour faire reconnaître son innocence
et de l'avocat patrick dils m florent a
innové en organisant une reconstitution
privée cet après-midi sur les lieux du
crime
car pour lui l'instruction a été bâclée
reportage valérie ermite et thierry
breton c'est un rendez-vous singulier
pour une reconstitution hors du commun m
fleuron l'avocat de patrick dils a
convoqué la presse pour une
reconstitution privée
une reconstitution sans magistrat sans
prévenu sans contradicteur et sans aucun
cadre juridique mais l'important pour
eux est ailleurs démontré les
contradictions du dossier
les corps des deux enfants était relevé
approximativement dans ce périmètre la
la c'est à dire à plus de 40 mètres de
l'endroit où patrick dils a situé les
deux crimes à schémas à l'appui
le comité de soutien de patrick dils
approuve sept ans qu'ils arpentent ces
voies de chemin de fer et plonge dans ce
dossier à la recherche
de la moindre incohérence la captive et
de patrick et les quatre pv situe donc
le décès de patrick l'institut dvd le
décès des enfants
à aucun moment il ne le situe là où la
lieux a eu lieu des crimes
à aucun moment au maire ce trajet est un
policier à la retraite il était l'un le
jour de la véritable reconstitution et
se dit aujourd'hui lui aussi convaincu
de l'innocence de patrice imaginez si ça
pouvait être mon fils qu'ils soient
présents et que quelqu'un sache de
détails comme ça qui se rajoute à
d'autres qui font une certitude
finalement ne disent rien une démarche
hors normes dans un dossier qui l'est
tout autant
en juin dernier fait rarissime la cour
de révision a ordonné un supplément
d'enquêté
car la présence de francis heaulme tueur
en série sur les lieux du crime est
maintenant avérée pour l'avocat de
patrick dils
il s'agit aujourd'hui d'accélérer le
cours de la justice
on a du mal à comprendre que la cour de
révision prenne tout son temps dans un
dossier qui devrait être prioritaire
puisqu'il s'agit certainement de la plus
monstrueuse erreur judiciaire que la
france ait connu une reconstitution sans
aucune valeur juridique
au risque d'agacer les magistrats en
charge de l'enquêté
un risque que l'avocat dit préférer à
celui du maintien d'un éventuel
innocents en prison un innocent et il en
prison depuis 15 ans peu à peu les
indices s'accumulent
patrick dils a été condamné à la
perpétuité pour un double meurtre
d'enfants à montigny-lès-metz mais il
clame son innocence
aujourd'hui un rapport des gendarmes
confirment bien que le tueur en série
francis heaulme étaient sur place au
moment des faits la cour de cassation
devra se prononcer le 15 mars prochain
luc laguerre boucher francis heaulme
travailler dans une entreprise à 300
mètres des lieux du crime
ses collègues de travail se souviennent
que son comportement a brutalement
changé dès le lendemain du double
meurtre perpétré en septembre 86 et
francis heaulme n'a plus d'alibi sa
grand mère et un ami qui affirmait que
le tueur en série était à leurs côtés au
moment du crime
ces deux personnes ont démenti tous ces
éléments nouveaux sont le fruit du
travail de la gendarmerie de metz chargé
par la cour de cassation d'un supplément
d'information
des éléments qui renforcent la
conviction de la famille dils pour leur
fils patrick condamné à perpétuité
8h 1989 n'est pas coupable s'attendre à
prouver l'innocence de notre fille suit
ce que de plus en plus à des éléments à
charge contrôle et il n'a pas à charge
contre notre fils maintenant il faut que
ça aille vite faut calade
la cour de cassation prend une décision
plus rapidement possible le 15 mars
prochain
la chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation décidera si oui ou non la
condamnation de patrick dils doit être
annulée si en l'état du dossier
il la cour estime qu'il n'y a pas
d'élément nouveau permettant de douter
culpabilité alors je crains qu'elle
n'est pas la même lecture de la langue
française que moi et vous seriez choqué
je ne serais pas choqué je serai anéanti
comme toute personne de bonne volonté
qui a vu lé de ces dix et qui sait
parfaitement y compris nombreux
magistrats que dit cet innocent et qu'il
purge à la place d'un haut depuis 14 ans
pour un double crime qu'il n'a pas
commis
patrick dils sera bientôt fixée âgé de
16 ans au moment du double meurtre il
sera dans un mois
s'il a passé la moitié de sa vie
derrière des barreaux pour une erreur
judiciaire
c'est une première ou presque dans
l'histoire judiciaire l'avocat général
de la cour de cassation a lui même
demandé la révision du procès de patrick
dils condamné à perpétuité en 1989 pour
le meurtre de deux enfants de 8 ans à
montigny les metz en moselle
le condamné avait 16 ans au moment des
faits depuis on s'est aperçu que sur les
lieux du crime francis heaulme déjà
accusé de multiples meurtres n'était pas
loin reportage valérie ermite avec andry
sera et la réaction de patrick dils
malaria les envahir non content si la
fin de l'audience patrick dils vient
d'apprendre par téléphone que l'avocat
général demande la révision de son
procès l'attend des mois et des mois tu
as des claques agit du 14 au cachot peu
avant l'avocate générale de la cour de
révision dominique commaret disait
n'avoir aucune certitude mais une
conviction qui s'est peu à peu forgé
patrick dils a le droit d'être à nouveau
jugée à la lumière des derniers éléments
inconnus lors de sa condamnation en 1989
des éléments nouveaux qui porte un nom
et un visage celui du tueur en série
francis heaulme
l' enquête a démontré que heaulme connu
pour son extrême violence
travailler tout près du lieu du crime
qu'il n'a aucun alibi et qu'il a croisé
le chemin des deux enfants assassinés
quatorze ans que la famille de patrick
dils attendait ce moment
cette demande de révision du procès
aujourd'hui je suis ape ému quoi
mais je vois comme une chorale bout du
tunnel si des erreurs ont été commises
il fois que l'institution et les hommes
aient le courage de les reconnaître
je crois qu'on est en bonne voie dans ce
dossier ce qui est je dirais terrible
c'est qu'il ait fallu tant de temps sur
le banc de la cour de famille de
souffrance et de lectures radicalement
opposées du dossier pour la grand mère
d'un des enfants assassinés la
culpabilité de patrick dils n'a jamais
fait et ne fait toujours aucun doute
entre toutes ces certitudes toutes ses
convictions et ses doutes
la cour de révision tranchera
définitivement le 3 avril prochain et de
mana cour de cassation se prononcera sur
un autre dossier celui de patrick dils
condamné en 89 pour un double meurtre
d'enfant mais le doute de l'erreur
judiciaire plane sur cette affaire et
demain patrick dils saura s'il
bénéficiera d'un nouveau procès dans ce
cas il pourrait retrouver la liberté
après 14 ans de prison dont confrères de
nancy st mathieu et yves quemener se
sont rendus chez ses parents
d'où ils ont pu s'entretenir avec lui
par téléphone leur reportage
celui dont tout le monde parle depuis
des mois celui qui jusqu'ici ne s'est
exprimé que par téléphone c'est lui
patrick dils il a 31 ans et il a surtout
la particularité d'avoir passé la moitié
de sa vie en prison
quatorze années derrière les barreaux il
a été condamné à perpétuité en 1989 pour
le meurtre de deux enfants meurtre qu'il
avait d'abord avoué cuisnier aussitôt
dans quelques heures la décision rendue
d'ici par les magistrats de la cour de
cassation pourrait bouleverser sa vie
tout à l'heure patrick dils par
téléphone nous a confié ses impressions
je suis également confiant mais
la sérénité et la confiance ne
l'empêchent pas dans un second temps le
stress angoisse et puis la nervosité
parce que bon on n'a jamais été aussi
proche du but
et puis
avec les dernières heures sont
extrêmement durs à vivre c'est
angoissant qui m'angoisse le plus c'est
l'histoire de la liberté c'est
uniquement ça logique voudrait que si
l'objectif
ces procès en mettant liberté comprenez
pas c'est pendante attention derrière
les murs en étant innocent et là dessus
j'ai acquis ses parents l'ont bien
compris
cette fois ci c'est la dernière chance
ils ont pourtant de bonnes raisons
d'espérer car il y a quinze jours
l'avocat général a requis son maintien
en détention certes mais aussi la
révision de son procès l'heure est donc
venue de décider décider si oui ou non
dans ce dossier la présence et les
révélations de francis heaulme constitue
un élément nouveau de nature à faire
naître un doute sur la culpabilité du
condamné
quoi qu'il en soit si patrick dils était
libérée ce serait une première dans les
annales de la justice française et la
reconnaissance d'une très grosse erreur
judiciaire
la sphère patrick dils maintenant la
cour de révision va se prononcer cet
après-midi sur la condamnation de cet
homme de 31 ans condamné à la prison à
vie pour le meurtre de deux garçons en
1986 à montigny-lès-metz
pour bien comprendre cette affaire le
rappel des faits maintenant avec fanny
au vernis ces marches qui mènent à la
cour de révision
les parents de patrick dils les ont
gravi maintes et maintes fois
cet après midi il espère que ce sera la
dernière
après trois ans d'enquêté la cour de
révision doit trancher
il ya trois semaines l'avocat général
avait demandé l'organisation d'un
nouveau procès pour patrick dils après
14 ans d'attentats clamé son innocence
enfin c'est l'espoir comptant en 1986 à
montigny-lès-metz patrick dils avoue le
meurtre de deux enfants puis se rétracte
lorsqu'en 1989 il est condamné à la
perpétuité
personne ne connaît encore l'existence
de francis heaulme
depuis la présence du tueur en série est
avérée
sur les lieux le jour du crime il
travaillait dans la région et a même
menti sur son emploi du temps de
nouveaux éléments troublants susceptible
de semer le doute sur la culpabilité de
patrick dils est d'amener la révision de
son procès dans sa prison à toul
patrick dils attend la fin de 14 années
de suspense dominique verdeilhan vous
êtes en direct avec nous depuis le
palais de justice donc ce n'est pas une
surprise à cette révision
elle n'est pas encore décidée on va
attendre une demi-heure mais c'est vrai
que si on ne fait pas beaucoup de
pronostics en matière de justice ça
serait une énorme surprise si les
magistrats ne décidez pas en début
d'après-midi de la révision du procès de
patrick dils puisque doute il y a ce
serait également un événement judiciaire
parce que depuis 1989 date de la
nouvelle procédure des révisions pénal
il n'y a eu qu'un seul précédent avec
reed allouche alors j'allais dire la
seule incertitude c'est l'éventuelle
remise en liberté dès ce soir de patrick
dils
ça serait logique eu égard aux textes de
la présomption d'innocence en vigueur
depuis janvier 2001
mais l'avocat général au cours de ses
réquisitions s'était opposé à cette
remise en liberté
d'abord au nom de l'ordre public et eu
égard aux familles des victimes
ensuite pour protéger patrick 10 jusqu'à
son nouveau procès alors un nouveau
procès si l'ia qui aurait lieu devant la
cour d'assises dès mineurs vous allez
dire c'est surprenant puisque patrick 10
est âgé aujourd'hui de 30 ans sauf que
ces larges au moment des faits qui
entrent en ligne de compte
et à l'époque patrice avait 16 ans la
justice a des doutes
la cour de révision a annulé la
condamnation de patrick dils à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité pour
le meurtre de deux enfants à montigny
les metz en moselle en 1986 patrick il
sera rejugé
mais pour l'instant il reste en prison
au portage valérie ermite avec vincent
fourcade et emmanuel bec
la salle d'audience est bondée le public
ne s'y est pas trompé
l'instant est rarissime la cour de
révision annule la condamnation de
patrick dils demande à ce qu'il soit
reçu j'ai tout en refusant sa remise en
liberté
c'est ce qu'on attendait que enfin le
jugement soit cassée il que patrick sont
reconnus maintenant présumé innocent
nous savons qu'il n'a jamais commis ce
double crime cette fois-ci gérer la
vérité est en marche rien ne peut
l'arrêter il sera rejugé dans un délai
extrêmement rapide par la cour d'assises
de la marne
siégeant à reims et à partir de là il
est évident qu'il sera acquitté
d'interview en interview parents et
avocats répète ce même mot historique
l'histoire d'un très long combat
familiale et judiciaire
1989 patrick dils est condamné à la
perpétuité pour le meurtre de deux
enfants
dils a avoué mais très vite s'est
rétracté une première demande de
révision est rejetée car il n'y a aucun
élément nouveau en 1997
un gendarme de rennes le genre d'un mac
brasles entend parler de la sphère
disent les deux meurtres pour lesquels
il a été condamné lui rappelle soudain
quelque chose
et pour cause francis heaulme tueur en
série notoire lui en avait déjà parlé
cinq ans plus tôt allmand lui avait
décrit une voie ferrée à
montigny-lès-metz et deux enfants
retrouvés morts
à l'époque le gendarme avait bien sûr
cherché mais n'avait rien trouvé
car patrick dils ayant déjà été condamné
l'affairé était classée et retirait des
fichiers des enquêteurs c'est ce nouvel
élément la présence avérée de francis
heaulme sur le lieu du crime qui a
conduit la cour de révision a demandé la
tenue d'un nouveau procès la fin de 14
ans de procédures pour la famille dils
et la saveur retrouver ta mère de
chantal il s'agit peut-être d'un nouveau
rebondissement dans la sphère dils alors
que la cour de cassation vient de
décider la révision du procès de patrick
dils condamné vous le savez à perpétuité
pour le meurtre de deux enfants francis
heaulme le tueur en série aurait avoué à
ses codétenus être l'auteur du double
assassinat il avait déjà reconnu être
sur les lieux du crime mais avait
toujours nié avoir tué les enfants
les stèles mathieu philippe castillo
francis heaulme at il tué cyril et
alexandre en 1986 à montigny-lès-metz
depuis quelques heures les événements se
sont précipités
selon les informations publiées demain
dans le figaro magazine le tueur en
série déjà condamné à cinq reprises
aurait avoué le crime à ses codétenus
j'ai appris par ce client qui avait
quelque chose de très important à veut
dire à savoir ils l'avaient ils savaient
le deal était innocent et que l'homme
était coupable des faits pour lesquels
dils avait été condamné il lui a indiqué
que ce jour là il était sur les lieux
avec un routard d'emmaüs
il était passé devant ses enfants qui
leur avaient jeté des pierres lui était
revenue salalah heaulme un homme était
revenu seul avait posé sa bicyclette
badin semble-t-il d'un talus avait gravi
un sentier et ap retrouvez ces deux
gamins je n'ai eu aucune précision que
je n'ai pas demandé d'ailleurs sur la
façon dont les faits avaient été commis
heim aurait dit à mon client je ne peux
pas reconnaître ces faits sinon ma soeur
ne viendrait plus me voir au parloir
contacté par téléphone m jean marc
florand l'avocat de patrick dils a
aussitôt réagi à cette déclaration
erronée que patrick était parfaitement
lino sondés double crime de montigny
donc
révélation capitaine francis heaulme a
décompté dont je me réjouis car il
clarifie rompt définitivement la
situation vous permettront je n'en doute
pas d'obtenir rapidement la mise tout à
l'heure m liliane glock l'avocate de
francis heaulme s'est rendu à la prison
de metz pour rencontrer son client
si l'information était vérifiée et
confirmée elle pourrait peut-être
accélérer les choses pour patrick dils
mardi dernier la cour de révision des
condamnations pénales avait ordonné la
révision de son procès patrick dils
clame son innocence depuis le début il
est en prison à toul depuis 14 ans pour
ce double meurtre il avait été condamné
à perpétuité
et dans le même temps on apprenait que
le deuxième procès de patrick dils
pourrait avoir lieu au mois de juin
patrick dils devra encore faire preuve
de patience il attendra en prison son
procès en révision qui va se dérouler du
20 au 26 juin prochain ses avocats
avaient déposé une demande de mise en
liberté mais la chambre d'instruction de
la cour d'appel de reims s'est déclarée
incompétente aujourd'hui accusé d'un
double meurtre d'enfant il a déjà purgé
14 ans de prison et il ne cesse de
clamer son innocence
à reims clément weill raynal et salah a
gravi lorsqu'ils arrivent au palais de
justice de reims ce matin patrick dils
se doute que sa demande de mise en
liberté a peu de chances d'être acceptée
sur le visage du jeune détenu
on peut lire un très léger sourire
teintée de lassitude
j'avais c'est quelqu'un vous avez appris
à connaître qui est sage et qui est
confiant donc comme il me dit qu'un
certain sens de l'humour ont trop peu
chaud chaud pour lequel on peut lui
rendre hommage unis fait après 14 ans de
détention je suis encore prêt faire
quatre jours de plus mais pour les
avocats des familles des deux enfants
assassinés
patrick dils demeure le principal
suspecte celui qui lorsqu'il avait 17
ans avait avoué le double homicide de
cyril et alexandre avant de se rétracter
pour les parties civiles la présence du
tueur en série francis heaulme sur les
lieux du crime le jour du crime ne
suffit pas à innocenter patrick dils
pour nous rien n'est décidé rien n'est
joué bien évidemment
cette révision du procès n'entraîne
absolument pas li un sens de patrick
dils pour nous je reste toujours le
coupable
et vous savez que aulnay cité comme
témoin donc simplement comme témoin cet
après midi la cour d'appel de reims a
finalement rejeté la demande de mise en
liberté en se déclarant incompétente
les parents de patrick dils qui luttent
depuis des années pour sa réhabilitation
ont accueilli cette décision avec
philosophie
on n'est pas trop trop déçu parce qu' il
vaut mieux que patrick reste jusqu'au
procès comme ça que rabier se concentrer
sur son sur la faire et qu'en même temps
à ce moment-là il sortira que une fois
et il est blanchi
patrick dils restera donc en prison
jusqu'à son procès qui aura lieu ici au
palais de justice de reims dans trois
semaines
et dans ce procès qui se tiendra devant
une cour d'assises
rien n'est acquis d'avancé patrick dils
demeure accusé de l'assassinât de deux
enfants ce sera à lui et à ses avocats
de convaincre les jurés de son innocence
à partir de demain à reims dans le huis
clos de la cour d'assises dès mineurs de
la marne pendant une semaine
patrick dils accusé du meurtre de deux
enfants commis en septembre 86 sera jugé
ou plutôt plus exactement rejugé et
c'est une première en matière pénale car
patrick dils fut condamné à la prison à
vie en 1989 il s'agit pour lui de faire
reconnaître son innocence
en s'appuyant sur la présence du tueur
en série francis heaulme sur les lieux
du crime au moment des faits valérie
ermite et jean-pierre mieux tout
rappelle les principaux éléments de
cette affaire et les témoignages
contradictoires
là je vous montre la chambre de patrick
c'est restée la même depuis 14 ans la
ses collections de minéraux une
collection de pierres des livres des
maquettes l'univers d'un adolescent de
16 ans patrick dils
le plus jeune condamné à perpétuité de
france le 28 septembre 86,2 enfant de
huit ans ont retrouvé morts massacrés à
coups de pierres le long d'une voie
ferrée
sept mois après le meurtre patrick dils
arrêtait passe aux aveux désaveu
incomplet mais extrêmement détaillé
renouvelée des aveux auquel les parents
de patrick n'ont jamais voulu croire
ces aveux ont été extorqués essoufflé
souffler c'est sûr et certain
je mets ma main si patrick dils avant de
se rétracter à vous il n'explique rien
j'étais comme obliger poussé à agir
dira-t-il pour son avocat patrick alors
très influençable a sagement répéter une
leçon apprise par la police elle même
il sera d'ailleurs le troisième à passer
aux aveux
les aveux qui n'explique pas l'essentiel
le mobile du crime encore une fois c'est
quand même incroyable
patrick dils aurait en l'espace de neuf
minutes à mains nues avec des pierres
tué deux enfants qu'il ne connaît pas en
tout cas l'un pas du tout l'autre
pratiquement pas changé aucune raison
serait rentré chez lui aurait dîné
auraient regardé la télé ils seraient
allés se coucher vraisemblable il faudra
attendre 1997 et un rebondissement nommé
francis heaulme pour que la justice
s'interroge le tueur en série étaient
présents le jour du crime
une information qui ne change rien dans
la conviction profonde des familles des
victimes
patrick dils et pour elle le seul
coupable il a eu des abus à la chaîne
il a eu des abus il a commencé par ags a
fini par z il a tout du tout du tout du
tout du tout dix ans qu'on arrête ce
site et après il a dit je suis soulagé
bernard verley et l'ex directeur d'
enquête c'est lui qui a arrêté patrick
dils
quinze ans plus tard les policiers n'a
lui non plus aucun doute
si on me démontre par a plus b que x est
l'auteur du double meurtre avec des
éléments concordants par rapport aux
stations par rapport à ce que l'on
connaît
je serais étonné c'est pas pensable
c'est pas pensable conviction contre
certitude la justice
elle a douté et fait exceptionnel
patrick dils sera rejugé par une autre
cour d'assises à reims avec derrière lui
l'ombre d'un tueur en série depuis ce
matin mais ça huis clos feutrée dils est
rejugé par la cour d'assises dès mineurs
de la marne pour un
le meurtre d'enfants meurtre commis en
1986 double meurtre dont il se dit
innocent c'est une première judiciaire
du un élément nouveau la présence du
tueur en série francis heaulme sur le
lieu des crimes au moment des faits le
procès ouvert aujourd'hui devrait se
prolonger jusqu'au 28 juin
compte rendu d'audience valérie ermite
fanni au vernis et raymond chape l'art
un procès exceptionnel hors du commun à
plus d'un titre
un procès en révision rarissime dans les
annales judiciaires
le second procès d'un homme qui se dit
innocent et qui a passé près de 15 ans
de sa vie en prison
lorsque patrick dils ce matin par la
parole c'est pour réclamer que ce procès
là soient publics pour que je cite tout
le monde sache et entendre la vérité
c'est un procès qui est exemplaire à
tous niveaux pour l'histoire de la
justice pour le cas individuels de
patrick dills je dirais pour les
libertés fondamentales liberté du
citoyen donc je crois qu'un procès aussi
important que celui là qui est quand
même une première en s'entendant
l'histoire de la justice un procès de
cette taille là ne peut pas être à huit
clos dans une société démocratique
mais la cour d'assises de reims a refusé
que l'audience soit publique en vertu de
l'ordonnancé de 45 régissant les mineurs
patrick dils est certes aujourd'hui un
adulte de 31 ans mais il n'avait que 16
ans au moment des faits son nom qui
figuraient jusque là sur la porte de la
salle d'audience est vite cacher le
procès aura lieu à huit clos même ses
initiales logiquement ne devrait pas
être prononcé un second procès
exceptionnellement douloureux aussi pour
les familles des victimes soutenu par
des psychologues
un deuil toujours impossible à faire
quinze ans après les faits imaginez les
parents qui sont là au premier plan et à
qui on reparle
et comment les que les conditions de
de leurs enfants les commissions de mort
de leur enfant se sont déroulées sans
public et sans journalistes les débats
ont commencé à la barre un défilé
d'experts psychiatres et psychologues
chargés de dire si patrick dils a plus
passé des aveux parce qu'il était à
l'époque particulièrement influençable
une question essentielle de ce procès
sur laquelle certains experts divergent
et que d'autres ne veulent pas tranché
journée cruciale aujourd'hui au procès
de patrick dils ou les policiers qui ont
mené l'enquêté défilent à la barre et
disent leur conviction de la culpabilité
de patrick dils tentant ainsi de
justifier leur enquête valérie ermite et
raymond châtelard l'ex inspecteur
divisionnaire varlet est un homme
toujours très entouré
c'est lui qui a dirigé l'enquêté sur le
double meurtre de montigny aux
journalistes s'ils répètent à l'envi que
patrick dils n'a subi aucune pression
pour passer des aveux et qu'il est
forcément le seul coupable
vous n'avez toujours aucun doute
toujours pas
toujours pas jusqu'à ma mort je n'ai pas
de doute et je pense que c'est patrice
l'auteur du mur et je te montre par
l'anc est alors qu'il voulait la partie
concernant rôle ne m'intéresse
absolument pas des certitudes
apparemment partagé par beaucoup de
policiers de la pj de metz très tard
hier soir l'enquêteur marchegay est venu
expliquer à la barre
pourquoi heaulme et est innocent et deal
ce coupable un réquisitoire plus qu'une
des positions qui a fortement agacé les
magistrats et les avocats de toutes les
parties à sa sortie
l'enquêteur est plus déstabilisée je
n'ai rien à dire
c'est clair je pense que c'était un
témoignage partisans qu'il convient de
bannir c'est la raison pour laquelle les
parties civiles se sont élevées comme
l'avocat général et comme un étrange
contre ce genre d'attitude on leur
demande d'expliquer et fait des
constatations et rien de plus ils sont
partis une idée de base c'est cette
ville coupable ça doit être le coupable
il faut que ça soit les coupables et
apprennent en passant de ça peut ça doit
est faux et dangereux mais qu'il faut
tordre le cou un certain nombre
d'éléments techniques objectif pour y
arriver il y à 12 ans le témoignage des
policiers les aveux de patrick dils
avait emporté la conviction d uvre est
leur déposition et le premier tournant
de ce procès en révision lundi prochain
ce sera au tour de francis heaulme de
déposer le tueur en série qui était tout
près du lieu du crime bénéficiera alors
d'un statut inédit à la fois témoin et
forcément suspecte que l'arrière de
patrick dils lors de la troisième
audience de son procès en révision
le meurtrier présumé de deux enfants
accusé un policier de lui avoir extorqué
ses aveux valérie ermite l'écrin
facteurs varlet restée près de quatre
heures devant la cour d'assises son
témoignage était l'un des plus attendus
de ce préfet c'est lui qui a recueilli
les premiers aveux circonstanciés des
patrick ville aujourd'hui très
contreversé pour la première fois de sa
vie
patrick dils atria partie l'enquêteur
expliquant avoir avoué par lassitude
pour en finir avec la garde à vue et les
pressions psychologiques mais surtout la
fusion de lui avoir suggéré be queued et
ses aveux ce cas une nouvelle fois
longuement mieux le policier puis la
juge d'instruction
il ya deux ans lors du premier procès la
police accusé dérouler ses certitudes
aujourd'hui sont en quelques semaines le
à la loupe par la justice la cour
d'assises de la marne chargée de refuge
aux intrigues lille ne veut visiblement
laissé aucune zone d'ombré dans ce
dossier
la semaine qui s'ouvre sera marquée
demain au plan judiciaire par la reprise
du procès de patrick dils avec la
confrontation très attendue de francis
heaulme tueur en série à la fois témoin
et suspect dans cette affaire
retour sur les premiers jours d'audience
où la déposition des enquêteurs aura été
le premier tournante de ce procès à huis
clos
valérie a réitéré mon chat pelard le
face à face très attendu va pouvoir
commencer
l'ex inspecteur varlet qui a mené toute
l'enquète est appelé à témoigner
l'enquêteur a toujours cru patrick dils
coupable depuis des années l'accusé
clame son innocence durant plusieurs
heures
l'ancien policier a expliqué à la cour
son enquête qui quinze ans plus tôt l'a
amené à confondre patrick dils mais le
temps passe et a aussi changé l'accusé
face à l'inspecteur pour la première
fois patrick dils eux se lève et
proteste expliquant comment selon lui la
police la subtile m'ont amené à passer
des avoués des pressions psychologiques
mais surtout un scénario du crime qui
lui aurait été suggéré et qu'il n'aurait
fait que répéter un face à face et une
déposition d'enquêteurs très diversement
ressentie par les deux parties les
dépositions qui vient de faire son très
complète
alors il est normal que le président
s'interroge sur les éventuelles
pressions sur la suggestibilité de
patrick dils et cetera
mais à ceux à ces questions là j'suis
varlet semble répondre d'une manière
tout à fait clair l'avocat m
il semblait dire que patrick avait été
un peu mise à mal j'ai pas trouvé moi
j'ai tout le contraire que par patrick
là c'est vraiment bien exprimé hier
mon avis peut voir l'été
les audiences sont interminables
il est plus d'une heure du matin à
l'intérieur le policier puis la juge
d'instruction nie toujours toute
pression sur patrick 10 qui aura été le
plus convaincant devant la cour huit
clos qui interdit aux journalistes
d'être présent empêche définitivement
d'apporter une réponse demain ce sera
l'autre tournant de ce procès que tueur
en série francis heaulme va devoir
expliquer ce qu'il faisait tout près du
lieu du crime
le jour du double meurtre arras devant
la cour d'assises dès mineurs de la
marne toujours à huis clos
les jurés chargés de juger patrick dils
pour le meurtre de deux enfants meurtre
commis en 1986 ont entendu aujourd'hui
le témoignage de francis heaulme secteur
en série présents sur les lieux du crime
au moment des faits ils ont aussi écouté
un adjudant de gendarmerie qui a
longuement enquêté sur francis oms est
essentiel aux yeux de la défense de
patrick 10 pour démontrer l'innocence de
celui-ci
compte rendu d'audience valérie remettez
rémy poissonnier la prison de metz
il est 6h30 du matin dans ce fourgon
cellulaire francis heaulme est en route
pour aller témoigner
quelques minutes plus tôt patrick dils
arrive lui aussi au palais de justice de
reims
étrange d'image de l'arrivée de deux
suspect des mêmes crimes
sous le regard de la grand mère d'une
des deux victimes on veut savoir qui a
fait ça
qui que ce soit qui que ce soit qui ce
soit à qui que ce soit deux heures
d'interrogatoire des contradictions dans
son emploi du temps le jour du double
meurtre mais pour le reste
francis heaulme n'a pas bougé il a
répondu qu'il n'a jamais tué les enfants
qui n'a jamais tué qui n'a jamais touché
des enfants qui ne les a jamais vus et
ceci de manière claire nette et
indiscutable
à la question auriez-vous tué ses deux
enfants et vous pu tuer ses deux enfants
la réponse est oui mais je ne l'ait pas
fait avant haut la main l'ex gendarme
acb rahal est venu témoigner en 1992
lorsqu'il arrête le tueur en série
francis heaulme lui dit spontanément
avoir vu dans l'est de la france
deux enfants morts le long d'une voie
ferrée en 1997 lorsque l'enquêteur
entend parler de la paire dils
il fait immédiatement le lien est écrit
officiellement à la justice c'est la
première approche qui la lie jusqu'à
présent pour expliquer les marques pour
lesquelles il a été confondu dire que
c'est toujours une petite fenêtre comme
ça qu'ils expliquent les deux toujours
témoin où il arrive toujours sur une
scène de crime pour vous francis heaulme
est forcément impliqué de manière ou
d'une autre ils ont que jusqu'à présent
chaque fois qu'il a dit quelque chose à
chaque fois ils étaient présents sur le
site de crime et à chaque fois il a été
l'auteur des faits à la barre des
témoins francis heaulme s'adresse aux
familles des victimes
je vous donne ma parole d'homme que je
n'ai pas de suivre deux enfants puis de
manière assez énigmatique parle de
patrick dils
je ne le crois pas coupable dit il et je
lui souhaite bonne chance
le deuxième procès de patrick dils e
touche à sa fin de ma le verdict sera
rendu aujourd'hui la mère de l'accusé à
dialoguer avec son fils qui hier a eu
des difficultés à expliquer pourquoi il
n'avait pas tué les deux enfants
clément weill-raynal sanaa graby
pourquoi patrick dils s'il est innocent
avait-il avoué il ya quinze ans le
meurtre de cyril et alexandre 7 jours
d'audience et 1 très longue
interrogatoire hier de l'accusé n'ont
pas permis de répondre à la question les
policiers m'avait suggéré mes aveux a
simplement déclaré patrick dils dont la
personnalité demeure un mystère
à l'époque à 80 s est parlé par boko
voici ne presque pas là elle a parlé
mais il s'était largement pas assez pour
convaincre la cour vous espériez de
montage de bus
patrick on est une famille conséquences
sérieuses pas beaucoup on parle pas
alors il a parlé comme l'a pu avec ses
tripes car malgré tout si aujourd'hui
après 15 ans et après la révision qui
est même historique il ne peut quasiment
toujours pas à s'expliquer très
clairement sur le pourquoi les avez la
réputation
j'imagine ce que ça pouvait être il ya
quinze ans c'est donc un garçon qui ne
pouvaient pas communiquer et bien qu'il
ait grandi en prison qu'ils aient une
maturité des experts sont d'accord qui a
toujours beaucoup de mal n'ont pas
communiqué mais a communiqué ses
impressions même si à l'époque le jeune
homme n'avait que 16 ans ses aveux
continuent de peser dans le dossier de
l'accusation
patrick dils avait expliqué en détails
aux policiers puis au juge d'instruction
comment ils avaient massacré à coups de
pierres les deux enfants dont les corps
avaient été retrouvés le long de cette
voie ferrée lors de la reconstitution
il avait répété les gestes ni mais le
double crime dont il est accusé
sans protester de son innocence n'a pas
d'explication on n'a pas d'explication
alors on est dans une situation dure
pour la défense faut le reconnaître
parce que là dès qu'on aborde les faits
dès qu'on aborde le dossier
on s'aperçoit que ces déclarations ne
sont pas terrible terrible au niveau des
fai des déclarations des éléments et
puis terrible si au niveau des détails
qui sont donnés
si patrick dils est innocent qui donc
est le coupable peut être le tueur en
série francis heaulme présents sur les
lieux du crime
mais l'audition de francis paul lors du
procès n'a pas permis d'en savoir plus
c'est donc dans cette salle que tout va
se jouer demain soir à l'issue du
réquisitoire de l'avocat général et des
plaidoiries de la défense patrick dils
dans ce box écoutera les jurés de la
cour d'assises de la marne prononcer
leur verdict coupable ou innocent voilà
monsieur bonsoir le procès en révision
de patrick dils s'est achevée par un
dernier coup de théâtre la cour
d'assises pour mineurs de la marne l'a
condamné à 25 ans de réclusion
criminelle pour le meurtre des deux
enfants de montigny-lès-metz commis en
86 après six heures de délibéré les
jurés n'ont pas suivi l'avocat général
qui avait demandé l'acquittement sur ce
procès extraordinaire le compte rendu et
l'analyse de notre envoyé spécial
dominés
ayant un verdict rendu dans un silence
pesant les jurés ne regardez pas
l'accusé et tout a basculé au moment le
président a annoncé qu'à la question sur
la culpabilité de patrick dils la cour
d'assises avait répondu oui patrick dils
était à nouveau reconnus coupables
patrick dils était à nouveau condamné
pour double meurtre
étonnant patrick dils qui n'a pas
bronché à l'énoncé du verdict il s'est
levé il a quitté son box la salle
d'audience sans même se retourner vers
la salle vers le public vers sa mère qui
s'était effondré quelques minutes plus
tôt alors après ce verdict force est de
constater que révision ne veut pas dire
forcément innocence ne veut pas dire
forcément acquittement malgré la
présence supposée sur les lieux du crime
de francis heaulme
malgré une accusation qui avait requis
l'acquittement
patrick dils a été condamné à 25 ans de
réclusion criminelle
l'excusé de minorité qui aurait permis
une peine de vingt ans lui a été refusé
pourquoi 25 ans difficile de le dire
en tout cas après 14 ans de détention
provisoire patrick dils est en droit de
demander une libération conditionnelle
ses avocats s'interrogent sur
l'opportunité de faire appel de ce
verdict il n'y aura donc peut-être pas
de troisième procès de patrick dils
patrick dils restera en prison hier soir
les jurés de la cour d'assises de reims
n'ont pas suivi l'intimé conviction de
l'avocat général qui réclamait
l'acquittement
le jeune homme a donc été condamné à 25
ans de réclusion criminelle
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
judiciaire qu'un procès en révision
conclu une seconde fois à la culpabilité
stéphanie perez et salah à granby tout y
est re laisser penser que patrick dils e
sortirai libre de la cour d'assises de
reims
mais dans la soirée c'est dans un
fourgon de police et en direction de la
prison qu'il a quitté le tribunal
toujours impassible
sa mère son frère ses avocats sont
abasourdis contre toute attente et
surtout contre le réquisitoire de
l'avocat général
le jury populaire confirme sa
culpabilité dans les meurtres de cyril
et d'alexandre en 86 6 longues heures de
délibéré huit voix sur douze pour le
condamné à 25 ans de prison
expliquez moi
cette décision je comprends pas je
comprends pas non nous n'avons qu'à
comprennent pas non plus
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé la froideur la
passivité de patrick dils l'expliquent
peut-être selon les avocats des familles
des deux victimes
il fallait avoir peut-être une autre
attitude que celle qu'il a eue et
peut-être aussi que cette attitude qu'il
a eu pendant ces derniers temps depuis
la requête en révision en clamant
l'innocence qui n'a pas réussi à
démontrer qui n'a pas qu'il ne ressort
pas véritablement du dossier eh bien
peut-être que cette attitude là explique
des 25 ans prononcée pour les familles
des petits garçons qui écartaient
l'hypothèse francis heaulme le
soulagement après une journée lourde
d'incertitudes n'hésiteront sûr qu'il a
dit qu'elle avait eu d'égard les petits
garçons c'était pas de la fantaisie
on avait un dossier qu'il parlait on
habitait certitude on avait dit qu'on
avait des des confusions qu'il a des
faits terribles dont je vous ai toujours
dit qu'on pouvait pas inventé patrick
dils et ses avocats sont maintenant
confrontés à un choix difficile faire
appel et défendre ainsi son honneur ou
bénéficier bientôt d'une libération
conditionnelle puisqu'il a déjà passé 14
ans en prison
je crois qu'il faudra peut-être quand
même privilégié la voie de la de la
liberté conditionnelle tout en
poursuivant une action de révision je
continue de penser que francis on ne
finira par avouer ce crime et alors là
je n'aimerais pas être à la place des
magistrats pendant ces neuf jours d'un
huis clos hors norme
il n'aura été question que d'un team
conviction celle de la défense et de
l'avocat général contre celle de
l'accusation et finalement des jurés un
procès énigmatique à l'image de la
personnalité de l'accusé décidément
l'actualité de cette fin de semaine aura
été dominée par la sphère patrick dils
avec aujourd'hui à nouveau
rebondissement une autre première dans
les annales judiciaires puisque l'avocat
du condamné a décidé de faire appel dès
demain à troisième procès aura donc lieu
une troisième comparution devant
d'autres jurés un cas de figure
totalement inédit et exceptionnel afin
d'obtenir devant une nouvelle cour
d'assises l'acquittement peut-être de
celui qui continue de clamer son
innocence
joël bruandet jérôme soûlard et ses vins
gauthier
je ne me suis pas battu 14 ans pour en
arriver là vous faites comme vous voulez
mais moi je continue c'était vendredi
soir patrick dils vient d'être condamné
à 25 ans de réclusion criminelle
alors que l'avocat général avait requis
l'acquittement il annonce aussitôt à ses
avocats son intention de continuer le
combat
en choisissant de faire appel patrick
dils abandonne la possibilité d'une
libération conditionnelle
il devra donc attendre son troisième
procès en prison là où il a déjà passé
14 ans pour ses parents persuadés de
l'innocence de leur fils ce choix est
celui de l'honneur là il reste peut-être
allons à présent plus longtemps mais on
espère qu'au bout de troisième procès
sortir enfin libre et blanchi
c'est ça que nous on attend et patrick
ou 6 mai pour les familles des victimes
le prix de l'honneur sera lourd à payer
un nouveau procès avec encore une
douleur à vif
malheureusement on s'aperçoit qu'encore
une fois on est obligé de continuer
encore à se défendre finalement à
éprouver les sensations et les émotions
que nous réserve des nouveaux procès
donc c'est encore une épreuve
supplémentaire mais je dis je le
reconnais dans une commande usage dans
une perspective désormais tout à fait
différente car après les deux chances
qu'ils ont été donnés à patrick dils
cette troisième mon avis est un peu
superfétatoire depuis janvier dernier
un condamné peut faire appel d'un
verdict de cour d'assises une
possibilité que patrick dils a choisi de
ne pas refuser
et ce malgré la souffrance inévitable
imposé aux parties civiles vont que
cette poursuite de la procédure
correspond pour eux à une poursuite de
leur calvaire
malheureusement si ils sont victimes
nous avons quant à nous la certitude que
patrick dils est une troisième victime
et donc nous n'aurons pas le choix
quinze ans après le meurtre de cyril et
alexandre patrick dils devrait donc être
rejugé d'ici un an
ce sera alors la première fois dans
toute l'histoire judiciaire française
qu'un homme sera rejugé trois fois pour
le même crime et en direct de vézelay
mettrait jean marc florand c'est donc
vous qui allez faire appel des deux
mains
leurs premières questions très concrètes
avez vous rencontré patrick dils depuis
son retour en prison
est-ce lui qui seul à décider de cette
nouvelle comparution avez vous tenté de
le convaincre de le dissuader ou vous
êtes vous contenter de l'écouter
alors j'ai rencontré longuement patrick
dils après le verdict rendu par la cour
d'assises de la marne vendredi très tard
dans la nuit et nous a dit très
concrètement qu'il voulait continuer à
se battre et qu'il laissait à ses deux
avocats maître becker et moi même
le choix des armes donc après avoir
décidé avec ses parents et en accord
avec mon confrère becker nous avons
décidé de faire appel dès demain de
l'arrêt rendu par la cour d'assises de
la marne
alors on a un peu le sentiment que les
décisions se joue davantage entre la
famille de patrick dils et ses avocats
est ce à dire qu'il n'est pas tout à
fait apte à maîtriser son destin ou est
ce que c'est une fausse impression dame
ou non il est tout à fait il est tout à
fait apte à maîtriser son destin
simplement il ne maîtrise pas toutes les
questions juridiques extrêmement
complexe de ce dossier qui est une
première dans les annales judiciaires
françaises et nous a laissé le choix des
voies de recours qui nous paraissaient
des plus aptes à sauver son honneur
alors question encore très concrète est
ce que vous avez conscience qu'il y a
peut-être un certain risque à entamer un
troisième procès par exemple sur quelles
bases pouvez-vous dire qu'il aura lieu
par exemple dès l'automne alors ce qui
est sûr c'est que ce procès aura lieu
d'ici moins d'un an puisque les
différentes affaires comparables où il
ya eu un appel d'un arrêts d'assises ont
été ré audience et dans les six mois ou
dans les huit mois pour que nous pouvons
espérer que d'ici le printemps 2002
cette affaire sera rejugé par une autre
cour d'assises dans un autre département
vous avancer l'idée qu'il puisse
comparaître libre pour ce nouveau procès
c'était une conviction ou une
démonstration qui en fait pourrait
s'avérer aléatoire si vous savez bien
que certaines ambiguïtés dans les
lectures du droit est précisément de la
nouvelle loi
c'est une certitude on ce que l'
ordonnance de 1945 qui régit le droit
des mineurs la justice des mineurs
prévoit qu'à mineur ne peut pas être
placé plus de deux en détention
provisoire
or il a été très précisément du 30 avril
1987 au 23 janvier 1989 il est de
nouveau en détention provisoire depuis
le 3 avril 2001 donc il devrait être
libéré automatique pendant l'été alors
vous évoquez
la création d'un comité de soutien où
vous voulez faire appel à l'opinion
publique avec quelle personnalité pour
et dans quel but au fond l'idée si vous
voulez très simple patrick dils est
parfaitement innocents du double crime
qu'on lui impute à montigny-lès-metz en
1986 ce n'est pas uniquement la
conviction de la défense mais je
rappelle que c'est également la
conviction du représentant du ministère
public puisque l'avocat général au
procès de reims monsieur sarcelet a
réclamé l'acquittement après avoir
démontré pourquoi par a plus b deal
c'est innocent du double crime de
montigny à partir de là si la justice ne
veut pas entendre cette innocence alors
même que le parquet général chargé de
l'accusation réclame cette innocence par
un acquittement
je crois qu'il est nécessaire d'en
appeler à l'opinion publique et de faire
comme ça a été le cas dans certains cas
historiques célèbres appel à comité
national de justice pour 10 comme ça a
pu l'être pour dreyfus ou pour d'autres
condamnés moins célèbres merci m est
d'avoir répondait en direct à nos
questions la sphère patrick dils cet
homme de 31 ans condamné souvenez vous
une seconde fois récemment en assises
pour le meurtre de deux enfants en 1986
et qui a fait appel
il a demandé sa mise en liberté
provisoire en attendant son prochain
jugement
il s'est toujours déclaré innocent mais
n'a jamais convaincu les jurés et
l'avocat général de la cour d'appel de
lyon a requis ce matin son maintien en
détention
les parents de patrick dils espère
malgré tout yasmina farber thierry
breton patrick dils a changé d'âme il
plus de lunettes plus de moustache les
cheveux pour transférer de la maison
d'arrêt de reims
ils arrivent détendus pour cette
audience devant la chambre d'instruction
de lyon c'est sa deuxième demande de
mise en liberté
à 31 ans dils a passé plus de 14 ans
derrière les barreaux pour le meurtre de
deux enfants qu'il conteste la défense
espère sa libération pour préparer son
troisième coincé entre les jeux parce
que tu voulais c'est un garçon qui n'a
qui n'a quand même pas beaucoup évolué
en prison parce que la prison n'est pas
une structure d'évolution mais imaginez
le
ivre connaissant un petit peu la vie et
dans des mains amies en ce garçon là
sera france en mai ont bien complètement
il est 4 h pro sens positif du terme
il développera sa personnalité peu
loquace devant la cour d'assises dès
mineurs de la marne
dils n'avait pas convaincu les jurés de
son innocence alors qu'ils bénéficiaient
fait exceptionnel d'un procès en
révision
il avait été condamné à 25 ans de prison
pour lé meurtre d'alexandre et de cyril
deux enfants de 8 ans pour leur famille
une mise en liberté serait une
provocation
si on a dit à ses parents là à deux
reprises par deux procès
par deux jurys différents que patrick
dils était bien le coupable et qu'il
était bien assassins de leurs enfants
alors comment il voulait vous
qu'aujourd'hui ils acceptent ils soient
remis en liberté l'avocat général a
requis le maintien en détention de
patrick 10 la chambre d'instruction dira
mardi prochain s'il peut comparaître
libre en avril 2002 pour son troisième
procès en assises
une première dans les annales
judiciaires déjà condamné deux fois pour
les meurtres de deux enfants patrick 10
qui continue de clamer son innocence va
connaître son troisième procès fait
nouveau le journal le républicain
lorrain publie aujourd'hui des éléments
en tendant à prouver que le tueur en
série francis heaulme se trouvait sur
les lieux du crime qui sont reprochés à
patrick dils la principale information
est temps que francis heaulme aurait
avoué aux gendarmes s'est rapproché des
cadavres et vue
l'assassin qui ne serait pas patrick
dils christophe n'est là jean-pierre
pasta six mois de travail
120 témoins auditionnés d analyse
criminelle c'est une véritable contre
enquête qu'on menait les gendarmes de la
section de recherches de metz un rapport
qui fait état de nouveaux doutes quant à
la culpabilité de patrick dils
la présence de ce dernier au moment des
faits n'est toujours pas avérée
les tons revanche se resserre sur
francis heaulme le tueur en série
souligne le rapport a été aperçu sur les
lieux du crime par trois personnes dont
deux pêcheurs il atteste que francis
heaulme était non seulement à proximité
des lieux du crime
mais sur la voie de chemin de fer le
jour où ils le rencontrent que
deuxièmement il portait des marques de
sang suffisamment importante pour que
quinze ans plus tard le témoignage des
prêts des pêcheurs soient très précis
sur ce point les éléments de ce rapport
les avocats des parties en présence les
connaissent depuis plusieurs mois la
différence c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce sont
les gendarmes eux mêmes qui font état de
leurs doutes chez les deals c'est le
soulagement
eux qui n'ont jamais douté de
l'innocence de leurs enfants reprennent
espoir
le rapport ne donne beaucoup d'espoir et
beaucoup de choses qu'on savait qu'on a
qui a été dit à reims mais hélas la
justice en a pas tenu compte
maintenant c'est redit encore une fois
donc je pars que ça sera bon pour lyon
lyon où sera rejugé patrick dils dans un
mois maintenant les jurés de ce procès
vont forcément avoir connaissance de ce
rapport
reste à savoir s'il va les influencer
l'actualité judiciaire avec de mein
première dans les annales de la justice
française un troisième procès aux
assises pour le même homme et pour les
mêmes faits patrick dils ce sera rejugé
en appel
il compare à lyon pour répondre du
meurtre de deux enfants comme et près de
metz fanni au vernis frédéric mans
c'était il y a dix mois lors du deuxième
procès aux assises de patrick dils
il pensait y être innocenté verdict 25
en prison patrick dils qui a fait appel
va donc être rejugé pour la troisième
fois
quinze ans après les meurtres de deux
enfants sur une voie ferrée à
montigny-lès-metz
les gendarmes ont repris l'enquète à 0
cent quarante témoins auraient entendu
de nouvelles expertises
les enquêteurs s'interrogent sur l'heure
du crime qu'ils estiment plus
vraisemblable une heure plus tôt or à
cette heure patrick dils se trouve à 70
kilomètres de là francis heaulme le
tueur en série était quant à lui bien là
dans ce créneau horaire de plus de
pêcheurs affirment l'avoir trouvée à
quatre kilomètres du lieu du crime
le visage ensanglanté pour les parents
de patrick dils ces nouveaux éléments
devraient permettre d'acquitter leur
fils devrait arriver à ce que les nas
ans de patrick ça prouverait et blanche
et surtout à papa il faut qu'il soit
blanchi leurs logiciels est là il s'est
terminé non cause plus tout le monde
fait des fautes
pourquoi il il n'avoue pas qu'ils ont
fait une faute c'est le cul avant de se
rétracter patrick dils a reconnu les
deux meurtres plusieurs fois alors
depuis 16 ans les familles des victimes
sont persuadé de sa culpabilité
ça me pèse énormément plus caresses et
la nouvelle enquête ne changent rien à
leurs convictions
nous ce qu'on veut c'est la science un
cap et ça c'est lui mais il a donné des
précisions terrible je redis les
précisions que celle seule la sacem pour
les connaître
patrick dils a trois semaines pour
prouver son innocence
c'est le procès de la dernière chance ah
bon on va parler de ce procès sans
précédent
on l'a déjà beaucoup dit qui s'est
ouvert aujourd'hui à lyon car c'est la
troisième fois que patrick dils affronte
la cour d'assises pour le meurtre de
deux enfants tués à coups de pierres il
ya plus de quinze ans le premier procès
avait eu lieu en 89
le deuxième après une demande de
révision en 2001 et grâce à la nouvelle
loi sur l'appel en cour d'assises
patrick dils spot à nouveau tentait de
s'expliquer sur place première journée
d'audience dominique verdeilhan fanny
auvergne je ne connais rien de la vie à
31 ans patrick dils est déjà un vieux
prisonnier il a passé la moitié de sa
vie en prison pour la troisième fois en
13 ans il se raconte face à une cour
d'assises dès mineurs
une enfance sans problème avec des
parents aimants un cap2 cuisinier qui le
satisfait amplement patrick dils parle
avec abondance il se reconnaît naïf trop
gentil mais ce troisième procès est
public alors ses avocats en veulent plus
tout doit être dit même le pire
dils avoue avoir été violés en prison
j'ai l'impression d'être saâles dit il
il n'a plus rien à cacher plus rien à
perdre
il est mort dans répond du tac au tac
aux avocats des parties civiles avec la
bénédiction de ses conseils on l'a senti
à une ou deux reprises
peu agressif assez bien je souhaite
qu'il a carte blanche peut être aussi
agressif qu'il le souhaite il peut taper
du poing peut faire ce qu'il veut la
carte blanche la porte sa défense cette
publicité des débats at elle libéré la
parole de patrick disent tous ceux qui
étaient présents au second procès à
reims le reconnaisse mes questions
cette apparente décontraction et cette
pugnacité seront elles toujours présente
lors de l'examen des faits
revenons à la deuxième journée du procès
public en appel de patrick dils devant
la cour d'assises dès mineurs à lyon
seize ans après les faits une jeune
femme a confirmé sa première déposition
ce témoignage donne en effet une
indication de leur du double meurtre
un témoignage capital pour les parties
civiles en revanche ils cassent
véritablement la libye de patrick dils
compte rendu d'audience clément
weill-raynal ça la gamme qui face à face
les avocats de la défense et des parties
civiles tente inlassablement de
reconstituer de comprendre 15 ans après
les faits ce qui a pu se passer le 28
septembre 1986 le long d'une voie ferrée
de montigny-lès-metz c'est là qu'avaient
été découverts dans la soirée les corps
de cyril et alexandre mais à quelle
heure a eu lieu le double meurtre entre
17h30 et 19h a révélé l'autopsié à 17h30
patrick dils un alibi à 19 heures il
n'en a plus le dernier témoignage
témoignages mathis dit que les enfants
criaient fort
j'étais pas comme ça en cachette
derrière un fourré il parlait il jouit
rien ils s'amusaient et à partir de
17h15
mystère on n'entend plus du tout les
enfants les enfants devaient être cher
chez eux ils n'y sont pas la mer sa
folle qu'est ce qui s'est passé monsieur
entre 17h15 et 19 heures
mais l'accusation et les parties civiles
s'appuie sur un tout autre témoignage
celui d'isabelle deschamps une voisine
qui doit sa fenêtre avait entendu un
hurlement d'enfants peu avant 19 heures
c'est son témoignage
confronté à l'emploi du temps de patrick
dils qui avait orienté les soupçons des
enquêteurs sur ce dernier
madame deschamps un témoignage qui
on ne peut pas être mis en doute c'est
certain qu'il a entendu des cris des
cris qui devance suffisamment alertée
pour qu'elle aille voir son amie pour
qu'elle descende aider la mère qui était
en train de rechercher ses enfants parce
que c'était un clic il l'a bouleversée
pressé de questions par les enquêteurs
qui s'appuyait sur le témoignage
d'isabelle deschamps patrick dils avait
fini par avouer avec force détails le
double meurtre avant de se rétracter
patrick dils que l'on sent peut-être un
peu moins à l'aise dans le box qu'à
l'ouverture du procès devra au cours des
prochaines audiences s'expliquer sur les
raisons de ces aveux en france depuis le
début de son procès patrick dils affirme
qu'il a avoué le double meurtre de
montigny-lès-metz sous la pression
policière il était confronté pour la
première fois aujourd'hui à ses
enquêteurs et les méthodes de
l'inspecteur varley qui a mené le
dossier ont été remises en cause a lyon
clément weill-raynal salah graby quinze
ans après l'inspecteur bernard varlet
aujourd'hui à la retraite est toujours
fier de son enquête probablement la plus
belle de sa carrière
c'est lui qui avait eu l'intuition de la
culpabilité de patrick dils
c'est lui qui avait interpellé le jeune
homme et c'est lui qui avait recueilli
ses aveux il est plus que jamais à la
culpabilité de la patrie de ville je
vais pas changer c'est sûr
toujours pareil ce sont ces aveux qui
sont aujourd'hui contestée sur les bancs
de la défense
rompu aux techniques de la garde à vue
l'inspecteur varlet son équipe avait su
mettre patrick dils en confiance sans
brutalité ni pression ils avaient
longuement parlé aux jeunes garçons
nous avons réussi à ce qu'ils se
confient spontanément raconte
aujourd'hui l'inspecteur varlet il nous
a livré des éléments que nous ignorions
et que seul le véritable meurtrier
pouvait connaître patrick dils lui
affirme le contraire
j'ai été manipulé et je suis satisfait
que de façon très claire il était
démontré ce matin que les aveux de
patrick dils ne sont pas des aveux
spontanés moyens de défendre ça il a
rien pour se défendre
donc il à la seule chose qui peut faire
pour se défendre c'est dire qu'on leur
convient suggérer des réponses pour
faire tomber les aveux ils savent eux
sont là ils existent dans été réitéré
devant être mes collègues qui ont été
réitérées plusieurs reprises au juge
d'instruction réitéré devant les
psychologues et les psychiatres réitéré
le jour de la reconstitution quatrième
jour d'audiences et l'on en revient
toujours à la question centrale des
aveux pourquoi le jeune homme at il
avoué avec un tel luxe de précisions
cette question pèsera lourd dans la
balance à l'heure du verdict au procès
de patrick dils devant la cour d'assises
dès mineurs du rhône journée difficile
pour l'accusé au sa position a été
confrontée à celle du magistrat qui a
instruit la faire il ya maintenant 15
ans sur place dominique verdeilhan et
patrick day specker quinze ans plus tard
le juge n'a pas oublié les aveux de
patrick dils
j'étais sidéré cela faisait froid dans
le dos dans son bureau deal ça parlait
calmement longuement sans émotion d'une
manière réfléchie
lors de la reconstitution précise le
magistrat patrick dils a refait les
gestes
un détail près troublant il n'a par
situer le lieu exact des cris
je n'ai rien parce que je suis tenu à
l'obligation de réserve
mais à l'audience le greffier gérard
mathis cas évoque la comparution de
deals devant le juge
j'en ai encore la chair de poule deal
c'était ni terrorisé ni traumatisé bien
au contraire ils se libéraient il
parlait librement avec cohérence
mauvaise journée mauvaise semaine pour
patrick dils
il demeure néanmoins un malaise après
l'audition des policiers des magistrats
des erreurs des légèretés désuni seul a
donc compté la religion de l'aveu ce
procès certes celui du mensonge
seulement voilà qui manque en france ce
reprise demain du procès de patrick dils
avec le témoignage de francis heaulme le
tueur en série dont la présence ce soir
du double meurtre avait conduit à
l'annulation de la première condamnation
de patrick dils explications agnès
garder patrick dils n'a pas su
convaincre lors de cette première
semaine souvent maladroit et malmené par
l'accusation puis qui pourtant dès le
début de ce troisième procès a clamé son
innocence la fois de plus mais d'un
autre côté les enquêteurs de l'époque
honteuse aussi était déstabilisé par la
cour
la deuxième semaine qui s'ouvre demain
s'annonce donc cruciale car pour la
première fois il sera question de la
contre enquête menée l'an dernier 140
témoin rien entendu de nouvelles
expertises et surtout la preuve que
francis heaulme le tueur en série se
trouvait non loin du lieu du crime ce
jour là mais cela ne suffit pas à
troubler les avocats des familles des
victimes heaulme n'a qu'une constante
dans tous ces déclarations la seule
constante que j'y vois ce qui dit je
n'ai pas tué des deux enfants de mentir
le tueur en série viendra témoigner
mercredi devant la cour d'assises de
lyon autre témoignage essentiel qui
pourrait lui aussi faire basculer ce
procès celui de deux pêcheurs
quinze ans après les faits ils se
souviennent avoir croisé francis heaulme
le soir du drame le visage tâché de sang
et les rats gare l'actualité en france
c'est d'abord la deuxième semaine du
procès en appel de patrick dils avec un
témoignage très attendu celui de deux
pêcheurs qui affirme avoir vu le tueur
en série francis heaulme le soir du
crime
d'après eux son visage était ensanglanté
c'est la première fois qu'une cour
d'assises recueille leurs dépositions
compte rendu d'audience valérie ermite
frédéric bohn emile et joachim ont une
passion la pêche ce dimanche de
septembre 86 jour du meurtre
ils plient leur matériel et rentrer chez
eux lorsqu'ils découvrent francis
heaulme le long d'une voie ferrée à
quatre kilomètres du lieu du crime un
haut la main et recroquevillée et son
visage est ensanglanté c'est un mec qui
étaient affolés ça mais qui sur t2
j'ai pas il était bon il avait un visage
qui faisait peur un témoignage important
pour la défense mais qui agace les
parties civiles et de pêcheurs auront
attendu quinze ans avant de parler pour
la première fois dans ce procès patrick
dils peut souffler les regards se
tournent désormais vers francis heaulme
le tueur en série heaulme qui témoignera
mercredi nie toujours être l'auteur des
crimes mais il reconnaît aujourd'hui
avoir croisé les enfants en 1992 il
racontait déjà cette scène aux gendarmes
qui l'avaient arrêté en fait avec le
recul depuis plus de cinq ans d'affilée
sur fond ce sont ces affaires je peux
dire qu'il n'est pas directement la
sphère de montigny lès metz et du
meurtre de ses deux enfants et à chaque
fois qu'il a évoqué une affaire il était
participants cette affaire-là
d'ailleurs ce jour là même évoqué
d'autres petites histoires qui ont
trouvé des épisodes judiciaires ont été
confondus au il n'a jamais de mobiles
poursuit l'enquêteur ces meurtres sont
extrêmement violent et il a déjà tué à
coups de pierres demain d'autres
enquêteurs viendront à la barre des
gendarmes qui ont récemment repris
l'enquêté à zéro
leur conclusion est la suivante le
meurtre des deux enfants de montigny lès
metz porte la quasi signature criminelle
de francis heaulme a priori les avocats
de patrick dils ont marqué des points
aujourd'hui nouvelle enquête très
méticuleuse de la gendarmerie confirme
les doutes sur l'emploi du temps reste
les aveux l'accusé est un sentiment
toujours très partagés audiences suivis
par stéphanie perez et salah grammy à
leur arrivée à la cour d'assises de lyon
les gendarmes de la section de
recherches de metz se font plutôt
discrets ils savent que leur rapport est
très attendu d'un ton assuré le
capitaine hans expose ses conclusions
les deux enfants ne donne plus signe de
vie à partir de 17h15 or patrick 10 ne
pouvait être présent au moment du
meurtre
il semble résulter avec une quasi
certitude
qu'il était matériellement impossible
que patrick dils puis 7 sur les lieux du
crime
à l'heure du crime puisque à ce moment
là il était encore et au plus tôt
pont-à-mousson c'est à dire une ville
distante de près de 25 km devant kelly
d'hermès
la cour est troublé par le travail
extrêmement rigoureux des gendarmes de
metz qui ont recoupé près de 200
témoignages et éléments d'enquêté mais
le doute subsiste encore et toujours le
capitaine ans le reconnaît lui même
je suis abasourdi par les aveux de
patrick dils et les parties civiles en
profite
ces analyses arrive bien tard quinze ans
après les faits on connaît la fragilité
mais vraiment la fragilité des
témoignages fragilité de témoignages sur
des horaires je ne parle pas sur des
faits mais sur des horaires on peut
quand même se poser la question si
quinze ans plus tard un raisonnement
intellectuel de ce genre
tenir la route je pense qu'ils défendent
une thèse qui est celle notamment
d'impliquer hall dans cette histoire
parce qu'ils ont peut-être une
impression un sentiment selon les
enquêteurs ce double meurtre présente en
effet la quasi signature criminelle de
francis heaulme le tueur en série a déjà
nié à huit reprises être le meurtrier de
deux petits garçons
sa déposition de main est très attendu
s'il a les clés d'énigmes les
donnera-t-il c'est toute la question
le dossier patrick dils et reste marquée
par le doute la journée d'audience était
très attendue avec le témoignage de
francis heaulme une nouvelle fois le
tueur en série affirmé qu'il n'était pas
le meurtrier des deux enfants une
audience suivi par stéphanie perez et
jérémie drieu la déposition de francis
paul était extrêmement attendu à tel
point que la petite salle de la cour
d'assises de lyon n'a pu accueillir tous
les passionnés de la faire
heaulme les épaules voûtées parle avec
difficulté
il regarde patrick dils je pense souvent
à lui dit il
mais comme à reims il répète je n'ai pas
tué les deux enfants
je suis un tueur en série mais j'en ai
marre qu'on me met tout sur le dos je
suis un bouclier émissaire baffo itil
quant à ses déclarations sur l'homme en
ce sens qu'il a vu il affirme avoir dit
n'importe quoi parce que le capitaine
ans présents dans la salle ne le
respectaient pas
il a été égal à lui-même c'est-à-dire
qu'il a dit n'importe quoi
une chose et son contraire
on d'intervalle
et eux
je crois que ça permet peut-être de
mesurer sa sincérité finalement pas ce
qu'il dit des choses qui ne sont pas en
sa faveur il dit chaque fois qu'on
m'interroge c'est une nouvelle version
le procès piétine mais la défense de
patrick dils restent persuadées de
l'implication de om joue par exemple
très intéressant qu'à la fin ils disent
à madame beckerich de manière émouvante
je vous jure sur la tombe de ma mère que
je n'ai pas tué vos deux enfants
l'ennui c'est qu'il dit aux gendarmes 3
il ya trois semaines je vous jure que
c'est henri leclerc qui a tué les deux
enfants et que je l' ai vu le doute
persiste la confusion est telle que la
présidente du tribunal appelle même par
erreur l'accusé dils
patricot
il ne nous apporte pas d'élément
déterminant qui pourrait
l'incriminé dans cette histoire avait
dans cette affaire alors on reste
toujours sur la même situation avec un
dossier particulièrement accablant qui
concerne patrick dils nous on n'a pas de
réponse
francis heaulme affirme avoir dit
n'importe quoi sous la pression des
enquêteurs
les défenseurs de patrick dils savent
maintenant que s'ils veulent obtenir
l'acquittement du jeune homme
ils doivent prouver que lui aussi a pu
dire n'importe quoi sous cette même
pression
le procès de patrick dils i après le
témoignage hier devant la cour d'assises
du rhône des experts psychiatres qui ont
vu en lui un homme normal c'est
aujourd'hui au tour de ses parents de se
rendre à la barre sur place stéphanie
perez et jérémie drieu les parents de
patrick dils témoignent en premier
fatiguée nerveusement après 15 ans de
bataille ils savent qu'ils jouent leur
dernière chance il est innocent s'il
était coupable je me serais suicidé je
n'aurais pas supporté d'avoir engendré
un monstre dit jacqueline deals malgré
la tension la famille dils veut croire à
une issue favorable à ce troisième
procès est la troisième procès mais
c'est celui pour nous est le mieux
et le plus juste pour nous parce qu'elle
a vraiment la présidente elle interroge
vraiment tout le monde elle va au fond
des affaires et le s'attarde pas sur les
détails
non je suis confiante j'avais et
éprouvant mais bon je ne peux pas passer
là pas de quoi
les familles des deux petits garçons
arrivent plus discrètement
elle ne parle plus aux deals elle reste
convaincue de la culpabilité de patrick
et rejette l'hypothèse pohlm très
éprouvé les mamans et les grands-mères
ont déjà quitté l'audience à plusieurs
reprises ces deux dernières semaines
c'est très très dur à vivre de
réentendre
le déroulement des faits la manière dont
ces enfants ont été massacrées dans des
conditions atroces et également
les dénégations
d'une personne que la justice de leur
pays et qu'ils ont confiance leur avait
livré on l'avait désigné comme coupable
il ya 14 ans quatorze ans plus tard on
leur dit ça n'est peut-être pas le
coupable est à la suite du procès de
reims on a eu confirmation que c'était
bien le coupable
innocent pour les siens coupable pour
les familles des enfants chaque jour la
balance a penché d'un côté puis de
l'autre cette deuxième semaine qui
s'achève n'a pas permis d'éclaircir le
mystère de montigny-lès-metz le verdict
très attendu sera rendu mercredi
prochain en france patrick dils vit des
heures cruciales il sera demain s'il est
acquitté ou à nouveau condamné
aujourd'hui le procureur n'a demandé
aucune peine aucune condamnation à son
encontre
il requiert le bénéfice du doute à la
cour d'assises du rhône stéphanie perez
et jérémie drieu embarrassé françois
louis coste l'avocat général quand il
arrive
d'un côté il y à ses aveux répétés de
patrick dils inhumain si détaillé qu'ils
en sont insupportables voyez vous dit il
en pointant du doigt il y as saison si
j'avais eu à requérir j'aurais demandé
votre condamnation
seulement voilà il n'y a pas de mobile
les repères chronologiques sont
incertains et francis heaulme était là
le doute est omniprésent pendant les
trois heures d'exposé un doute tels que
l'avocat général ne requiert ni
l'acquittement ni la condamnation
un fait rare dans les annales
judiciaires si le doute l'emportent 2 gr
âce patrick dils ne venait pas disputer
la place de victimes
vous avez pris la place du meurtrier
vous n'êtes victimes que de vous même il
laisse des jurés
dans un abîme de réflexion profonde qui
est son abîme à lui l'avocat général qui
est de se dire malgré trois semaines de
débats je ne peux pas quitter l'habit du
doute
il n'a pas même le courage de prononcer
le terme d'acquis pour tous
pour protéger l'institution judiciaire
ça évite de mettre en cause
d'institutions judiciaires en termes de
responsabilités ça évite de parler
d'erreur judiciaire quel équipement et
on fait tout retomber la faute sur un
gamin de 16 ans les familles des deux
enfants elles sont plutôt déçus encore
qu'on pu très bien parce que quand on
dit ça quand on grandit comment les
codes sont habitués à des questions
verrerie qu'ils ont été tués tout ça
pique on vient nous dire là on va voir
au bénéfice du tout on comprend plus
très bien nous sommes dans une
incertitude certaines en quelques mots
l'avocat général a résumé les dignes
dils tout repose donc désormais sur les
épaules des 12 jurés
demain ils devront choisir entre le
bénéfice du doute et leur intime
conviction procès de patrick dils
maintenant l'heure est aux plaidoiries
après un réquisitoire du procureur
général qui l'a exprimé que des doutes
sur la culpabilité de l'accusé vallée
des ermites frédéric dans la dernière
ligne droite celle où il faut tenter de
convaincre les indécis transformer le
doute en intime conviction celle de
l'innocence de patrick dils
les avocats de l'accusé le savent leur
plaidoirie est essentiel puisque la
veille l'avocat général n'a pas levé
toutes les ambiguïtés n'a pas clairement
montré le chemin de l'acquittement
au delà des doutes de l'avocat général
la défense elle a une certitude
d'innocence et nous allons tenter de le
démontrer l'avocat général est habité
par le doute
tout est douteux dans ce dossier dit il
mais il est aussi habité par la colère
suscitée par les aveux effroyable de
patrick dils
ils ont tout balayé comme un torrent
dévastateur dit il ils ont envahi la
raison et si vous bénéficiez du doute
monsieur dils
ayez une nouvelle pudeur vous avez pris
la place du meurtrier
ne venez pas disputer celle des victimes
vous n'êtes victimes que de vous même on
dit comment les coptes ont été tués avec
quelques sauvagerie qu'ils ont été tués
tout ça puis combien nous dire
on va voir au baisser du tout on
comprend plus très viable
le doute de l'avocat général et les
certitudes diamétralement opposées des
avocats des parties civiles et de la
défense le verdict très attendu tombera
dans la journée en france les jurés de
la cour d'assises dès mineurs du rhône
sont en délibération depuis plus de
trois heures maintenant
et le verdict concernant le procès de
patrick dils devrait tomber dans la
soirée
ce matin la parole était aux avocats de
la défense ils ont demandé
l'acquittement
l'acquittement mais l'incertitude
demeure à lyon stéphanie perez et
jérémie drieu pour ses dernières paroles
avant que la cour ne se retire patrick
dils hausse le ton c'est la première
fois je suis innocent je suis désolé de
vous avoir fait souffrir dit il aux
parties civiles
mais je n'ai pas tué vos enfants
aujourd'hui je voudrais vivre
je veux que tout ça s'arrête je suis
fatigué pour le clan dils
l'heure de vérité a sonné la fatigue se
lit sur tous les visages plus que
quelques heures d'attentes
après quinze longues années de procédure
peu près trois procès
oui
non non ça va bien se passer
je pense quand même que
doit parfaire la même faute qu'ils ont
fait avant
vous êtes confiant on est confiant
parce que si là il faut qu'on la même
faute alors je ne comprends plus rien
tour à la justice pendant cinq heures de
plaidoiries les deux avocats du jeune
homme de 31 ans jettent leurs dernières
armes
bertrand becker défendent hills depuis
15 ans ayez le courage de reconnaître
l'erreur judiciaire messieurs les jurés
patrick dils est la troisième victime
innocente de ce procès et m florent de
poursuivre le temple judiciaire sera
ébranlée mais il se reconstruira tout
seul
ne pensez pas au scandale ce que je
souhaite c'est pour ça que j'ai insisté
sur ce point c'est que les jurés du
courage
s'ils ont du courage et une intime
conviction je pense qu'ils l'ont il sera
acquitté
j'espère qu'ils ne seront pas les
gardiens du temple et qui ne coûteront
pas les sirènes leur disant pas de
vagues pas d'erreur judiciaire
condamnant l' 15 ans est libre de match
où on est content non parce que il nous
faut une décision courageuse et décision
courageuse et décision d'acquittement
devant le tribunal le comité de soutien
de patrick dils a pris place pour
attendre le verdict
les délibérés ont commencé à 16h30 les
maman d'alexandre et de cyril elles ne
sont pas venus cet après midi elles ont
la certitude que dils est coupable et
qu'il doit être condamné voilà priorité
à l'actualité nous retournons à lyon car
à l'instant on connaît le verdict dans
le procès de patrick dils
dominique verdeilhan patrick dils est
acquittée par les jurés du rhône oui et
vous entendez probablement david pujadas
derrière moi les applaudissements les
mêmes applaudissements qui ont rententi
il y à peine cinq minutes dans la salle
de la cour d'assises lorsqu'il a fallu
attendre la cinquième question et
lorsqu'à la cinquième question la
réponse fut non cela veut dire donc que
patrick dills est acquitté ça veut dire
qu'il est reconnue donc innocent de ce
crime pour lequel il avait été
précédemment condamné par deux fois
normalement donc patrick dils va être
libéré dans l'eure où leurs ennemis qui
vient depuis la prison saint paul où il
était incarcéré pendant la durée de son
procès ensuite il y aura pour lui un
autre combat qui sera celui de
l'indemnisation après ses 15 ans de
prison
15 ans de prison est aujourd'hui un
acquittement patrick dils où vient de
retrouver la liberté après 15 ans de
détention qu'il a quitté il ya moins
d'une heure la prison saint-paul de lyon
la cour d'assises du rhône l'a innocenté
du double meurtre de montigny-lès-metz
ce nous écoutons tout de suite la toute
première réaction de patrick dils
extrêmement content de retrouver la
liberté
même si j'en mesure par an pour le
moment encore toutes les conséquences
mais
très content de passer à autre chose que
la prison les murs des barreaux
l'univers carcéral
il ya des moments vous avez tout et
j'écoutais sur 400
il faut pas ménager de l'acquis en
prison elle est rose et puis il ya des
secours même si on est innocent au fond
de son coeur en france les ses tripes
c'est en images
j'ai pas une machine visant les actions
se faire dire là dessus rien n'est
jamais acquis
on était obligé de l'équipement mais
également une nouvelle condamnation
c'est tombé
j'ai eu du mal à respirer et puis j'ai
que j'ai compris qu'une fois que le soir
tout seul le bloquer ça y est enfin de
l'air m
se retrouver devant une situation et
j'attends les 10 15 ans mais voilà
quelques foyers plus récentes et dieu
pourquoi aujourd'hui vide mais ç'a
toujours été non
mais j'ai jamais les assurés
ça manque déjà de le dire je veux
retrouver ma famille je peux retrouver
mes amis je suis là premier conseil je
vais travailler dans
le
je serai très travaillés en aucun point
de la nuit et reprendre
avant le travail déjà retrouvé la
famille et puis bien évidemment
rapidement les travailleurs on va y
aller alors avec vous de me libérer en
revenons sur cette affaire patrick dils
pendant quinze ans on s'est basé sur les
aveux de l'accusé alors que la justice
française on le sait officiellement est
basé sur la preuve est la preuve
et l'épreuve il n'y en avait pas oui
tout à fait les aveux six fois réitérés
de patrick 10 en quelques jours et est
le seul élément à charge vous l'avez dit
il n'y avait aucune preuve il n'y avait
aucun indice aucun témoin aucune
empreinte pour soutenir l'accusation
les pièces à conviction qui sont en
général devant les jurés au fil des
audiences avait été détruite en toute
légalité en 1995 deal c'était donc j'ai
à dire son propre accusateur des aveux
crédible et un accusé qui dans le box
étaient difficilement convaincant des
aveux qui par deux fois ont emporté la
conviction des jurés à metz et à reims
avec une inconnue quand même à lyon
s'agit-il d'un verdict d'innocence ou
bien le résultat d'un doute qu'ils
avaient été soutenus vous en souvenez il
ya deux jours par l'avocat général alors
on a entendu un instant même rôle en
reparler de réparation comment peut-on
réparer s'il s'agit d'une erreur
judiciaire
oui peut-on indemniser peut-on réparer
15 ans la moitié d'une vie pour patrick
dils alors ses avocats vont se tourner
devant la commission d'indemnisation de
la détention provisoire il demande la
somme de 2 millions 300 euros c'est à
dire peu près 15 millions de francs le
record pour l'instant s'élève à un
million et demi qui a été donné à un
ancien administrateur judiciaire de
nanterre pour six mois de détention
provisoire
à l'opposé rida louche qui a été
acquitté après un procès en révision
indemnités zéro franc les magistrats ont
estimé le site l'erreur judiciable est
imputable à l'intéressé c'est un
précédent fâcheux pour patrick dils dès
sa sortie de prison patrick dils est
effectivement rendus dans un lieu tenu
secret pour retrouver sa famille et ses
amis des moments très forts qu'il
espérait vivre depuis des années il a
accepté de se confier à nous par
téléphone de nous faire part de son
émotion en écoute il soufflé
et puis on s'est tous regardés il ya eu
quelques larmes de lâcher et cuits à la
joie d'être ensemble
c'est un moment très simple mais ô
combien important et ô combien magique
je dirai pas ce que ça n'a rien à voir
avec le contexte d'un parloir
ça n'a rien à voir avec l'univers
carcéral s'est tous les cas tu es libre
la liberté ne mettez pas tout simplement
a peur parce que ben tant que parent je
la connais pas je vais découvrir demain
je sais pas si on pourrait s il vous est
vraiment le bon mais un peu les
naissances donc quelque part c'est non
rien ne me fait peur je vais apprendre
et puis je serais passé les rangs on ne
peut pas oublier 15 ans et je ne veux
pas oublier ces quinze années parce
qu'elles sont lourdes de conséquences
et je vais surtout qu'une telle erreur
ne se reproduise jamais dans le futur
j'aurais alger mener un combat pour les
aptitudes et puis j'ai l'intention qui a
beaucoup de choses à ce niveau là j'ai
pas mal de projets et je ne peux pas les
un nouveau pass existe en prison
avec un chaos si faible qu'elle voit ça
c'est hors de question
or avec des premiers patte de liberté
pour patrick dils qui termine une
semaine après quinze années derrière les
barreaux
le témoignage de cet homme qui va enfin
selon ses propres termes faire
l'apprentissage de la vie à 31 ans fanny
auvergne et rémy poissonnier nous
rencontrer cet après midi à paris c'est
la première fois qu'ils visitent paris
première journée d'homme libre
pour patrick dils qui retrouve les
choses les plus simples c'est magique
c'est rempli de couleurs c'est rempli de
vie et moi de la vie ça fait quinze ans
que comme on a privé donc le bruit de
l'eau l'aller les oiseaux le vent mais
odeurs patrick dils découvrent la
liberté le public lui doit faire sa
connaissance
ce n'est plus l'adolescent très timide
que l'on décrivait mais un adulte
parfaitement capable d'exprimer ses
émotions
quelque part j'ai même eu peur peur
parce que c'est trop beau est ce que
demain matin quand je vais me réveiller
il y aura encore tout ça parce que
je vais pas boire de nouveau des murs à
l'épi nouveau une porte fermée on
j'ai bien compris que j'avais été
acquitté et puis qu'on m'avait rendu mon
honneur et puis ma dignité ainsi que
celle de ma famille mais pour l'instant
ce sont que des mots il dîne en vouloir
à personne mais il exprime des doutes
sur la justice lui qui a été innocenté
après trois procès aux assises
si j'étais victime d'une erreur
judiciaire je suis sûrement pas un cas
unique
je suis sûr que dans les prisons
françaises
il ya de nombreuses personnes qui sont
enfermés mais qui n'ont pas eu ma chance
d'être médiatisé qui n'ont pas eu ma
chance d'être entendue patrick dils va
travailler dans une imprimerie
mais il espère plus tard pouvoir
témoigner de son passé judiciaire dans
les facultés de droit
invité du 19/20 donc patrick pas de
patrick dils
bonsoir elle soit et merci d'être venus
en priorité sur le plateau du 19-20 vous
allez retrouver la liberté et votre
honneur depuis six mois maintenant
qu'est-ce qui a été le plus agréable
pour vous et qu'est-ce qui a été le plus
difficile le plus agréable c'est d'en
trouver mes proches mes parents mon
frère pour aller prendre dans mes bras
et puis bien nous retrouver mon honneur
parce que c'est quand même une bataille
de 15 ans et quelle bataille
maintenant qu'est-ce qui a été le plus
difficile je dirais bien c'est de faire
face aux ennemis aux administrations
pour battre comme tout le monde dans la
légalité
c'est à dire avoir sa carte d'identité à
voir enfin préparer les papiers pour le
permis de conduire
enfin des choses simples la vidéo aux
yeux de l'administration existe vous
êtes le détenu dils voilà ne plus être
numéro franchement est ce que est ce que
vous avez tout de suite su quoi faire de
votre liberté ou es ce que vous avez été
un peu désorienté absolument pas j'ai
tout de suite su quoi faire parce que
j'ai pas perdus montée en prison j'ai
peut-être pas vraiment fait des études
mais j'ai
en tout manutention travail et donc
travaillé quelques jours après ma
libération
pour moi c'était c'était logique c'était
normal quand est ce que je voulais plus
simplement une femme tout le monde
donc j'ai travaillé et j'ai pris des
vacances après pour bien montrer à tous
ceux qui ont cru en moi et bien que le
patrick dils qu'il était en prison
c'est le même qui est sorti et c'est le
même il y en a pas deux des patrick dils
ya pas de clown
patrick dils il est là aujourd'hui en
face de vous il veut vraiment réussir sa
vie
alors vous vous avez parlé un petit peu
de vos premiers jours de travail vous
avez passé un peu plus de deux mois à
paris et franchement ça n'a pas dû être
très facile j'imagine que le choc
le passage entre une cellule de 15
mètres carrés et la vie à paris ça a dû
être assez assez dure pour vous ça a été
terrible parce que les noirs et je
passais au blanc c'est à dire que
j'allais vraiment dans la capitale ce
qui est plus grand ce qui ce qui bouge
le plus donc je compare un petit peu
avec mes mots je dirais la capitale à
une fourmilière
les gens ne prennent plus le temps de
vivre les gens me prennent prennent plus
le temps de d'apprécier les choses
simples de la vie
je crois malheureusement il faut en être
privé pour vraiment se rendre compte que
la liberté mais c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus important
vous avez acquis en fait paradoxalement
une philosophie en prison pour après
quoi pour après vous avez entièrement
raison je dirais que j'ai fait l'école
la plus dure l'école de la vie la prison
elle m'a emmené aussi elle m'a forgé un
caractère et je crois que après avoir
vécu ces quinze dernières années
derrière les barreaux
je suis prêt à tout il n'ya plus rien
qui peut le faire peur alors justement
vous dites l'école la plus dure vous
avez écrit un livre qui donc sera publié
jeudi prochain j'ai l'impression que
vous avez écrit un livre comme on tourne
une page un petit peu comme si vous
vouliez tourner la page
pourquoi est ce que vous avez décidé
dans ce livre de tout raconter y compris
les humiliations les plus difficiles de
vos codétenus
mais ça va partir du moment où j'étais
amené à le dire à la cour d'assises je
savais que on a les deux nouveaux morts
parler un jour ou l'autre
alors j'ai pris mes de vent mais j'ai
dit bamba puisque j'avais l'intention
déjà avant de sortir de préparer un
livre je me suis dit balle et on balance
tout on en dit tout et puis on laisse
tranquille
des gens veulent savoir eh ben ils
achètent le livre et ils sauront mais il
faut plus venir me demander oui qu'est
ce que tu as vécu à présent comment ça
s'est passé
non il ya un livre qui est très bien
fait et
toutes les réponses sont à l'intérieur
et vous dit à la fin de ce livre que
maintenant votre rêve le plus important
c'est de retrouver l'anonymat
oui c'est ce qui est le plus important
pour moi parce que le côté célébrités
d'ailleurs c'est un mot que je n'aime
absolument pas puisque je ne suis pas
une vedette je ne suis pas une célébrité
juste une victime du système judiciaire
alors effectivement il ya des gens qui
vont mettre une vie pour devenir célèbre
et moi je prends je vais mettre le
restant de mes jours pour essayer ce qui
sera loin d'être évident de retomber
dans l'anonymat
patrick dils merci beaucoup d'être venu
sur le plateau du 19h je rappelle le
titre de votre livre qui sort donc jeudi
en librairie
je voulais juste rentrer chez moi et
c'est édité chez michel lafon
merci justice un million d'euros 1
million d'euros pour avoir passé 15 ans
en prison pour rien c'est
l'indemnisation comptes obtenues patrick
dils et sa famille information du
républicain lorrain
patrick dils rappelons le avait été
acquitté du meurtre de deux enfants
après toutes ces années de détention
c'est le montant le plus important
jamais accordé christophe medard
jean-pierre pasteur les rideaux sont
tirés la porte reste close la famille
dils n'a pas souhaité réagir aux
informations révélées par la presse
locale les habitants de
montigny-lès-metz ne s'en prive pas et
ils sont unanimes
très honnêtement je pense qu'avec lui
méritait plus je pense que j'avais
vraiment pas grand chose pourquoi la
petite goutte d'eau qui tord aux gloires
pas parce qu chez lui à face à moitié
fait toute ma vie quoi condamné à
perpétuité pour le meurtre de deux
enfants à montigny les metz puis
acquitté en avril 2002 patrick dils doit
percevoir 700 mille euros de dommages et
intérêts une somme qu'il estime
justifiée au vu des 15 années passées en
prison
j'aurais préféré ne pas toucher un
centime et ne pas avoir vécu toutes ces
galères ce que j'ai vécu ne se chiffre
pas son avocat lui plutôt satisfaits et
naturellement supérieure à la première
offre qui avait été faite par l'agent
judiciaire
le montant final est le plus important
jamais attribué en france dans une
affaire d'indemnisation de détention
provisoire abusive l'état devraient
aussi verser 200 mille euros à la
famille de patrick dils cent mille euros
étant allouée au titre des frais de
justice
l' enquête sur le double meurtre de
montigny-lès-metz elle n'a toujours pas
abouti
[Musique]